pur pendant quelques secondes mais je
suis revenu je suis de nouveau ici
j'ouvre un petit peu toutes mes fenêtres
tous mes chats je suis désolé j'ai été
coupé
mais je suis je suis là j'ai réouvrir ça
comment je fais pour voir ça
[Musique]
attendez un
je vais essayer de retrouver
le chat aussi de YouTube
et
hop je suis vraiment désolé voilà j'ai
reboot et j'ai eu un problème de de
d'électricité ça c'est
tout éteint alors j'ai même perdu les
caméras vous voyez vous imaginez bien la
partie est là
et les caméras je vais essayer de vous
les remettre très vite
donc attendez je suis en train d'essayer
de voir ça
ça
quoi est-ce que
c'est pas pourquoi ça me prend pas ma
cam
[Musique]
je vais faire un truc
un petit souci de caméra
ça va revenir très vite
façon
[Musique]
OK
et je vais vous mettre les caméras ça
arrive
premier ça arrive hop
où est-il à
ça c'est lui
normalement si je mets la 1 à peu près
marcher
mais là il va pas marcher
et je ne sais pas pourquoi je vais pas
marcher
je pense là
je vais pas non plus
écoutez je ne sais pas j'ai un petit
souci là je tourne plus rien ne marche
je vais vous remettre quand même le
temps
à mettre quand même le temps
des parties
c'est quand même le plus important
et du coup je vais partir je pense sur
cette vue là parce que je n'ai pas les
caméras donc mieux si on est comme ça
voilà toujours pas non plus pas trop sur
celle-là ok j'attends un petit peu les
caméras qui vont je pense reboot très
bientôt
et en tout cas désolé pour cette petite
interruption
donc on disait que
ta bataille et lasalik
il veut la partie alors là du coup j'ai
raté tout raté un je me suis arrêté par
là et une pièce de moi il se passe quoi
j'ai raté beaucoup de choses
et il s'est passé ça le cavalier à plus
de 15 ah oui dur très très dur pour
pour
tabac à bec qui va s'incliner avec les
Blancs qui va s'incliner et qui va
laisser du coup la victoire à
laser
qui a perdu hier contre contre carvana
en Armageddon c'était très très chaud
pendant ce temps là j'ai préparé au bout
de la scène des
[Musique]
des parties et puis
je le rends qui m'a répondu
ok donc je vais
là pendant que ça se termine il va
perdre très bientôt je vais préparer la
selle de
juste après et on va avoir du coup
c'était Magnus manus avec les Blancs
donc ouais j'avais tout préparé à
l'avance là
qui a lâché
[Musique]
au bon moment c'est toujours cool
toujours cool de voir ça
alors en deux on va avoir
Fabian
je sais pas si c'est la bonne
et après on va avoir encore
avoir so Wesley
et je vais avoir aussi à lire les
affiches
plus trop d'intérêt il y a une pièce net
de moins
pour ça que je voulais je vous le
commente pas
c'est pas ultra
[Musique]
intéressant et à lire les raisins
pour
pour la partie suivante
je le charge je le cherche je le cherche
et
iPad là
alors attention apparemment que les
Noirs font plein d'incisions là on voit
ça
et je vais essayer maintenant de mettre
les caméras dans le studio et pour
Magnus
c'est un peu rageant que tout marche
bien
tout marcher si bien
et au final
plus rien ne marche encore
et pour
ça va faire
la
ça va du coup la 4
ça devrait marcher normalement tout à
l'heure
j'espère que les joueurs
pas mentir OK
tu fais jamais coiffé non
alors
sur quelque chose de parti
bon je crois que je suis plus ou moins
remplacé comme tout à l'heure j'ai perdu
les caméras dans tout ça alors il y a eu
ça échec
on voit ici c'est là mais après
c'est compliqué
je pense que c'est juste perdu la
position de tabac d'abeille elle est
complètement finie
complètement fini malheureusement
des dames
le roi blanc il est dans des réseaux de
maths
voilà forcer
qui a l'air qu'elle est intéressante
c'est pas encore maths il y a ça
dame là pas mal aussi voilà il faut
finir c'est pas encore maths il faut
terminer pour
comment est-ce qu'on termine ici
forcer cette cavalier G7 voilà
tour
et ta mèche là sur ici il va y avoir
peut-être un échec en bas aussi
il y a plein d'échecs possibles
françaises t'arrache les deux ouais
c'est ça
abandon de la part de de tabac abeilles
qui a donné une pièce à cette partie
vraiment dommage pour lui c'est une
position il pouvait un peu pousser et
donc là David qui va passer dans les
quarts de finale maintenant dépervant je
vous montre un peu le bracket
il est ici regardez bien vous avez
Carson Carvin qui vont rentrer en lice
maintenant vous avez so Nakamura qui
vont commencer tout de suite aussi en
même temps que personne et Carola et en
dessous dans les perdants que vous avez
Tabata Bay et ln off qui sont éliminés
avec l'âge et à notre offre qui
attendent les perdants des demi-finales
qui vont se jouer maintenant
donc là ce qui est marrant ce qu'on peut
voir c'est que
filou si jamais hyper contre sobre il va
rejouer contre Abdou qu'il la joue dans
le premier tour donc c'est assez c'est
assez marrant et voilà on va un peu
comment ça se passe donc je vous propose
qu'on se fasse une mini pause maintenant
avant de t'entamer les demi-finales avec
Arsène Caravana et Sophie Rosa pour que
j'ai le temps de replacer toutes mes
caméras et tout ce que j'ai fait tout ce
que j'ai perdu pendant que j'ai eu ma
coupure d'électricité voilà donc je vous
dis à tout de suite et je reviens dans
un instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour
pour rejoindre un mauvais tour
donc Magnus contre karwana ça va
commencer dans un instant maintenant oui
je peux changer le
le quart en demi-finale
hop donc là on a une super super finale
enfin super de mec qui arrive avec
Magnus contre
Caravana super affiche et on va avoir
d'ailleurs juste en dessous on va avoir
aussi so Wesley qui va affronter
qui va affronter le français Ali resa
firous juin donc deux grosses grosses
affiches en tout cas ça va être hyper
cool hyper intéressant et donc on n'a
pas encore les couleurs de cette
première partie mais ça va pas tarder à
vivre en tout cas vous voyez les joueurs
qui sont qui sont installés et prêts et
prêts à jouer ma minus qui mange qui a
l'air en forme
ah bon
tout le top 10 chouchou
alors
les appareils sont pas encore créés chez
moi
on va savoir les couleurs
dans un instant
s'ils sont aussi
installés regardez bien il y a ceux qui
en bas contre Ali Raisa ils sont prêts
ils sont prêts à
se mettre sur la gueule
mon train a du retard à Zurich ça marche
sous XOS
ta connexion azurique où est-ce que tu
voyages sur xoslo qu'est-ce que tu fais
où vas-tu
raconter un petit peu ta vie
alors cette blague pas loop on la
connaît un
de Vienne à Lausanne OK
alors Vienne moi je suis à une fois j'ai
trop trop aimé mon
mon voyage là va Vienne c'est une trop
belle ville d'ailleurs j'en connais un
sur le chat qui habite pas très loin de
Vienne maintenant qu'il y a déménagé il
y a très très peu c'est juste une box
salut à toi
ça va très bien j'espère que tu vas bien
aussi
salut ta Vienne
je ne savais pas tu vois
je ne savais pas
maintenant je le sais
en fait je sais pas qui tu es en vrai
donc
je ne te connais pas je te connais avec
ton pseudo elle sait que tu es tu es
très très souvent sur notre stream
mais c'est vrai que je ne te connais pas
viennent en Isère je pense que c'est
je crois que c'est Viana non en Autriche
plutôt plus sympa
tu es une
j'ai toujours pas les appareils
si je l'ai ma carte avec les Blancs n'a
pas mardi et ça a commencé on a aussi
ici la partie donc
la partie de l'IRESA qui va commencer
dans un instant c'est qu'il y a toujours
un petit décalage entre les parties et
donc ça commence par une par une
espagnole
je vais remettre le son du site c'est un
peu mieux quand il y a des coups
je préfère avoir les l'annonce des coups
quand même
et c'est une expérience très classique
ici
joué par par Magnus et Fabi donc ça
c'est rend les gros derby c'est vraiment
les joueurs qui sont joués je ne sais
combien de fois dans leur vie
il y a des gens qui ont failli se
rejouer en finale de la Coupe du Monde
malheureusement pour Fabi il a été
stoppé par un petit indien un petit
indien du monde de Prague
et
d'ailleurs j'ai vu que Prague il a fait
il a participé derrière le champion du
monde
par équipe en rapide et il a fait un
score monstrueux encore Prague il est
extrêmement chaud en ce moment
donc tout remuide l'idée de manger ici
un jour et de manger un 4 à ta pression
sur le plan
c'est vrai que la Magnus c'est l'air de
bien manger
et
espagnol à ce niveau là c'est quand même
c'est quand même
vachement jouer il y a une partie un peu
comme ça ou Magnus Labège contre
H3 foot France n'est pas la même
position mais
alors ici comment est-ce qu'on joue à ce
qu'on joue pour défendre le petit pion
en 4 est-ce qu'on joue tout romain pour
le défendre un peu par la transparence
qu'est-ce qu'on va jouer ici parce que
le pion en E4 je suis pas sûr que ça
prenable par exemple je fais un com H3
est-ce que vraiment je peux manger le
pion je ne suis pas sûr on va imaginer
que je mange du pain ici
mais il y a aussi un autre coup que je
voulais vous mettre
[Musique]
qui est hyper thématique dans toutes ses
positions
c'est pour ça qu'au final ce pion en 4
n'est pas encore bien défendu mais là je
te rends vous voyez il s'en fout du pion
4 et maintenant ça il a fait froid prise
et qu'elle avait des B4 mais l'option il
est pas prenable à chaque fois la tour
ce problème de flux V5 si jamais tu
viens
prendre scorpion E4 ils le savent tous
les deux donc il lui avait les B4 avec
de faire C5 généralement dans ces
positions
et en plus elle va les BK mine de rien
ça empêche des cinq donc ça peut
préparer éventuellement un cavalier
prend un cadre qui va les prendre ton
coin parce que Freezer ne sera plus
possible pour l'instant mais c'est ça
que ça reste quand même l'idée numéro 1
de la position
donc assez assez intéressant
donc il y avait des bécasses que
qu'est-ce que va nous jouer ici Magnus
avec des blancs
[Musique]
les cavaliers des trois qui est
intéressant qui est une menace
ça me fait un peu peur parce que je mets
sur la colonne de la tour
j'aime pas trop ça en plus
des éventuellement
faire attention j'ai bien sûr aussi il
faut baisserdes qui aussi une vraie
menace sur le pion encore que j'aime pas
du tout madame en vis-à-vis de la tour
ça c'est pas du tout ce qu'il faut faire
du coup est d'un coup qui est assez
logique qui permet de de roquer avec la
tour mais en fait
plus sérieusement d'un bien ça ça
contrôle la Catastro du cavalier
sa menace plus tard de faire A3 sans que
tu devenait
éventuellement 5 pour venir après
attaquer sur le roi en H7 donc dame bien
c'est un coup assez souple mais c'est un
coup assez bizarre quand même
généralement c'est pas là qu'on met
qu'on met la dame aux échec c'est pour
ça que tu m'as eu je dois comment se
poser la question de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans cette partie
je vais
c'est un tout petit peu à gauche j'ai
l'impression qu'il est un petit peu trop
un petit peu trop loin
un peu mieux comme ça
soupe et bizarre c'est ça
ben c'est un coup qui empêche ça c'est
une grosse menace et puis ça permet
d'accompagner aussi le Pione quand je
l'aurais poussé ça m'offre des cases
comme la case de 4 qui fait un soutien
par Madame
ça c'est intéressant
poussez de mes fous c'est ça donne ça
donne le fou et vous savez à quel point
la perte de fou elle est importante
dans ces dans ces positions on n'a pas
envie de donner nos fous gratuitement
comme ça avant vraiment fou ces deux
cavaler procéder c'est le rêve de noir
ici donc l'idée c'est de faire ça
imaginons je suis pas sur un coup comme
toutes ces cinq c'était quand même
l'idée là je peux jouer des coups comme
A3 etc mais dans l'idée en fait ce que
je veux faire c'est un jour virer ce
cavalier et peut-être même passer la
dame avec le foot arrière et maintenant
menacer un truc par là-bas par exemple
vous voyez mais c'est pas le mettre de
le dans la dame comme ça c'est
pas du tout l'idée de la position en
tout cas c'est pas ce que je veux et
Manu ce qui prend beaucoup de temps dans
la partie c'est pas quoi faire
alors qu'ici en plus l'idée des Noirs
c'est en fait après c'est 5
je peux jouer à 3 ici sur un coup comme
dessin
un peu comme une Benny en fait c'est
typique de cette position cette
ouverture de la de l'espagnol et cavaler
la etc
ça c'est hyper hyper normal si je fais
des cinq avant pour empêcher le cavalier
de venir ici mais je crois que l'idée
ici c'est de faire il y a plusieurs
idées mais je crois qu'à 5 reste un coup
il me semble pour avoir la case à 6 pour
le cavalier au cas où par exemple à 5 à
3 Caval est là plus tard c'est 4 et 5
un truc comme ça qui est doit rester ici
possible donc c'est vraiment des
pollutions assez assez intéressantes en
tout cas les structures qui sont
marrantes
donc c'est très souple comme comme idée
quand tu joues il y a la jauge mais en
fait la jauge même si je joue un bon
coup et ben à chaque fois très souvent
elle descend elle monte même si je l'ai
beaucoup mais après c'est vrai que je
l'ai beaucoup de bêtises ça c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai que des fois par exemple
d'un bien
c'est cool c'est le coup de la jauge
enfin c'est le bon coup la chose qui
descend qui monte quand même là le
meilleur coup c'est C5
je le joue elle descend elle remonte et
elle redescend alors que c'est les
coudes
un petit peu comme ça quoi
donc voilà faut pas trop trop faire
attention à la jauge en plus le le
stock fille le cheescom comme ça il est
il est
il est pas si bon que ça parce qu'il
change quand même beaucoup d'avis
donc pas trop trop regardez tout ça par
contre Magnus qui prend quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de temps dans cette
partie
et la vidéo où je n'avais pas du tout
et sur dame 2 il y a eu c'est 5 alors
moi je disais ici tout à l'heure je
parlais de du coup à 5 qui était une
idée aussi pour que ça par contre la
jauge va aller vraiment pas d'accord et
là je suis là je te l'accorde et de
loyer mais mais sinon c'est ça qui a été
le tempo
et c'est qu'un but de la variante mais
j'aime pas le fait d'avoir une dame en
face de la Tour c'est pas un truc que
j'aime bien
ces nouveautés alors malheureusement
j'ai avec mon je regardais
apparemment j'ai des parties
sur la base de James
une fois
et bien une fois
voilà
et donc après
un coup c'est 5 qui a été joué et là A3
a été joué une seule fois je sais pas
vous dire
c'est qui la partie on est un
c'est 2450 contre 25,50 ouais c'est pas
des c'est pas des grands génies pour
servir des bons joueurs mais
la référence de ma venue
donc il a fait à 3 d'ailleurs je crois
dans la partie à 3 c'est 4 c'est la
partie
donc voyez à quel point on veut vraiment
s'emparer du bout de 15 ans on en a
parlé dans le chat c'est par cette
position on voulait faire pousser deux
je dis qu'elle va les prendre a été
quand même assez embêtant que le fou il
est important dans la position il faut
le garder voyez et du coup après c'est 5
à 3 c'est 4 et par le fou c'est deux qui
devient
quasiment
quasiment perdu
qui est assez bizarre
c'est des bons joueurs c'est des très
bons joueurs par rapport à moi mais ce
que je veux dire c'est quand je te parle
de la partie de référence pour des
joueurs à 2800 hello eux ils vont pas
forcément regarder les joueurs à 24 50
2550 c'est le peut-être mal exprimé
c'est ce que je voulais dire parce que
moi bien sûr l'argent en dessous de ces
élans
donc clairement
mais c'est vrai qu'un malus Carlson il
va avoir que c'est imposition dans quel
genre de 2400
il s'en fout un peu quoi alors que moi
je trouvais ça intéressant vous voyez la
différence de préparation entre un
joueur et top niveau et un amateur comme
moi
je sais que tu blagues mais bon mais
c'est vrai que des fois des fois on a
l'impression que enfin même par rapport
par rapport aux gens du chat et bah
confondu qu'un joueur est mauvais alors
qu'il est quand même il est quand même
beaucoup plus fort que vous et c'est
vraiment par rapport à votre joueur bien
évidemment
vous savez que je me permettrai pas de
dire que les gens sont mauvais de toute
façon
alors d'un point ici là qui peut être un
coup ca va les prendre et 5 puis on
prend je perds madame donc ce qui va se
passer après qu'elle va les prendre des
seins c'est un bon métro sûrement et
donc on va perdre depuis on centrale
pour manger un pion des mais cette perte
de pure centrale peut nous donner quand
même un jour la possibilité
la colonne D et d'aller manger les pions
on va ce qui veut Magnus c'est faire
comme des quatre manger
le Puy en tout casier pour gagner du
temps et venir sur des belles cases
comme A5 pour viser la carte C6 j'aime
bien ce que fait Magnus quand même dans
cette partie la plus beaucoup de temps
la pendule mais j'aime bien ce qu'il
fait
tu largement sous tout
désolé aussi par gamer contre Dominguez
ok là j'ai pas la base qu'il connaît le
coup oui il doit connaître c'est clair
donc pas nourrir
tu es mauvais tu es mauvais hein
c'est pas vraiment un sacré fils
on peut le voir comment sacrifice le
fait de perdre un fou des fois c'est pas
ça mais des fois ça peut être vu comment
sacrifice
mais quand on a plus qu'un seul c'est
plus si grave que ça mais l'idée c'est
quand tu quand tu as les deux
des fois ça peut être un peu embêtant
parce que la paire de fou dans la
position ouverte c'est généralement
hyper fort donc vraiment essayer de
garder le plus possible
grâce à un moment quand même qu'il a les
problèmes de coiffeur c'est un petit
moment déjà
la partie la plus dingue en train de VL
ah oui mais
je mange tout vient mais je me souviens
aussi d'une sicilienne
où il y avait eu la sacrifice de partout
je crois que c'était la sienne avec avec
[Musique]
d'un B6 si je me trompe pas
je me demande si tu trouves pas ce soir
je crois que ce n'est pas une Espagnole
je crois que c'était une Sicilienne je
me trompe peut-être mais il me semble
que je
je crois que c'est ça je suis pas sûr
mais je crois bien que c'était une
Sicilienne
ce qu'on appelle un pur empoisonné ça
s'appelle
mais je peux me tromper aussi
merci beaucoup à Oussama papa excuse-moi
sur Youtube qui me félicite pour mon
titre merci beaucoup c'est vrai que ça
fait longtemps que je le cherchais et
puis finalement réussi par l'avoir ça
fait ça fait du bien ça fait plaisir
alors est-ce que vous voulez qu'on aille
voir un petit peu ce qui se passe chez
firou on n'a pas encore vu quand même on
va aller le voir
je vais sortir sa game à part elle est
là
et soit par contre j'ai pas la caméra de
sous pourquoi
serait-il pas là
un problème je la retrouve
elle est là
OK
alors la position
assez intéressante cette position
c'est une position très bizarre
cavalue au bord des fous au bord on va
essayer de voir ce qui s'est passé dans
la partie
je vais assez vite et indienne avec
cavalier à 6 OK
ça c'est les
qui sont blindés de blindés de théories
il y a vachement vachement vachement de
théorie
c'est très très compliqué
et on est comme ça apparemment le coup
au 3 c'était une grosse gaffe de la part
de raisin alors que ça a l'air quand
même un coup assez tentant de faire ça
pour le droit pour passer une gaffe
expliquez-moi monsieur
apparemment c'est pas bon à cause de
fois H5 c'est la bonne intrus
apparemment cavalier ici avec une Cabaye
étroit il est peut-être un petit peu
plus précis mais bon très compliqué
ça a l'air quand même pas mal pour les
pour les blancs l'histoire et maintenant
qu'on voit que le pion de 5 la des
problèmes qui à moi
qui va être joué
mais la position non maintenant alors
qu'elle est plus facile qu'elle va les
B3 fous des quatre échanger les fous moi
les gagne plus en sécurité c'est plus de
gaz intéressant en tout cas mais bon on
a vu hier un lit raisin qui a mis 3-0 à
Abdou Abdou quand même c'était un 7
toujours un candidat pour gagner une
tendance donc mes 3-0 c'est quand même
c'est vraiment quand même qu'il est
assez en forme et qu'il est chaud donc
du coup on va voir un peu ce qui se
passe à noter aussi que Wesley Sow il a
aussi gagné 3-0 contre helenov et c'est
pas un patron non plus il y en a enfin
donc c'est vraiment quand même de bons
résultats de leur part à tous les deux
et on va bien que les deux joueurs sont
quand même hyper hyper en forme
donc on va voir et cette position quand
même alors quand même pas mal pour les
blancs c'est une bonne c'est une bonne
étant bien pour les blancs faut G3 c'est
la partie c'est une bonne mais
l'avantage c'est que c'est une position
qui
de partout on entend tous les sens blanc
noir ça gigote et donc c'est les
positions que
Kali raisin aime bien parce que c'est
dans lequel il peut vraiment créer des
choses un petit peu
créatif dans cette position je pense
qu'il y a moyen de faire des choses
je sais pas quoi peut-être qu'avant je
pense
qui se regarde
prise et essayer de ramener un fou
quelque part mais bon peut-être qu'elle
va les prendre à 5 minutes en temps R4
on va essayer de enfin j'essaie en tout
cas de trouver des solutions même
cavaluer 5 est un groupe qui se regarde
parce que après cavaler en puis on prend
j'ai mon foot il peut venir prendre des
quatre on va éliminer un petit peu les
pièces il faut prendre j'ai pas encore
j'ai pas encore parlé tout bien ici il y
a tombé 7 et c'est assez chaud peut-être
fout des quatre civil de Caraïbes ou B6
mais c'est compliqué en tout cas je fous
le 5 il veut éliminer le défenseur du
roi il faut prendre pour prendre
et 7 ça va être la partie probablement
[Musique]
derrière c'est compliqué hyper compliqué
salut Victor et merci beaucoup pour ton
petit message
merci beaucoup
à la base en plus je voulais même pas le
mettre à mon titre de EMI sur jamescom
là-bas je voulais mettre feed encore
pendant cet événement parce que
parce que ben je l'ai pas encore eu
officiellement enfin je l'ai là je le
suis mais j'attends juste que le Congrès
de la fille de valide le titre mais je
me suis fait un peu devancer par nos
amis de cheescom qui quand ils ont écrit
les messages sur les réseaux sociaux les
miles ont marqué émis de partout du coup
je dis bon allez donc je l'ai mis mais
bon j'aurais j'aurais attendu encore un
peu plus pour ma part parce que bah
officiellement il n'est pas là encore
j'attends juste la belle validé ce sera
fait ça va être validé parce que
ça va être validé parce que
parce que j'ai toutes les conditions
pour l'être
mais il y a quand même un petit délai
administratif
on doit attendre
la jauge n'a pas aimé le coup de de saut
ça c'est une très bonne nouvelle
maintenant il faut continuer
un truc comme ça
c'est un petit mot de ma part
c'est tout le titre s'il te plaît
et dépêche-toi
après je compte pas avoir un bon moment
donc
[Musique]
en fait je sais pas a priori là j'ai pas
encore de de
comment dire
j'ai pas encore de toi prévu mais
peut-être que s'il y en a qui arrive
dans le coin parce que chez moi moi
j'habite à Valencia en Espagne et là il
y a beaucoup de tournoi des chèques en
fait on a tout le temps quasiment tous
les weekends
et toi moi c'est des tournois
Blitz rapide lente tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps donc
c'est intéressant ça permet de rester un
petit peu actif c'est cool
mais après il y a pas de tournage très
intéressant par là j'ai vu un tournant
de partie lente la semaine prochaine
c'est moins de 2400 euros
et le temps là dure une semaine il y a
une ronde par jour
et le premier prix c'est 300 euros donc
ça fait une semaine un petit peu un
petit peu tu vois tous les jours elle
fera partie des chèques pendant une
semaine pour avoir un prix qui est assez
ridicule
j'ai pas eu envie de participer
c'est pas c'est pas pour le prix parce
que je suis pas professionnel mais 300
euros sur une semaine sur un vrai
tournoi international ça va faire un
petit peu
parce que pour jouer des je sais qu'il
faut quand même que je que je
prenne congés quoi si vous voulez c'est
que je donne des cours d'échec c'est mon
métier je suis entraîneur donc si je si
vraiment je prends une semaine
j'aimerais faire un
vrai Tournai il y a quand même encore un
niveau un truc qui peut être sympa
ça fait même pas la paille avant
alors plus de 1400 hello maintenant
malheureusement
alors j'ai passé 2400 hello virtuel
pendant le peine d'avoine en France et
en fait après la peine d'avoir et ben
j'ai fait un tournoi en Espagne et je
voulais plus y aller parce que j'avais
réussi mon objectif de base de 1400 et
l'autre etc et j'ai pas envie d'aller
faire notre tournoi derrière alors je
vais réussir mon objectif
mais j'avais acheté l'avion j'avais payé
l'hébergement enfin j'avais tout quitté
je dis bon bah j'y vais quoi je t'ai
prévu
et du coup ben au final je perdais pas
l'eau mais heureusement que
virtuellement je suis passé de 1400
euros pour valider qu'un outil de mi et
maintenant j'ai beaucoup de points à
récupérer
à cause de mon intendant donc j'aimerais
bien me refaire un peu et aller faire un
trou noir pour pour remonter un petit
peu
c'est parti elles sont sortis
il y a un décalage d'une minute par
rapport
par rapport aux parties
la partie de Magnus on peut aller voir
un peu jeter un oeil on fait son on fait
un peu les deux un Magnus et là on est
ici
et il a plus ou moins rattrapé son
retard de temps
et une position plutôt bonne peut-être
tu auras un qui va arriver des beaux
cavaliers au centre le renard qui calme
un petit peu ouvert et bien je crois
qu'il est qui peut arriver à tout moment
j'aime bien la fournisseur de loin
mais il y a un reste encore tout tout à
fait
il est plutôt bien parce qu'en fait il
est il est il est pas à câble parce
qu'il est protégé et il y a le pion à 6
qui a un pion arrière
et donc le cavalier qui quand même
contre les cases assez importantes dans
le gaz noir la potion noir et après
cavaler V7 l'idée c'est que sur
d’apprendre les 7
et bien il veut faire il va nous faire
un clouage qui veut changer du matériel
et faire un peu le ménage et grâce à
cavalles
beaucoup plus classique toi
un souvenir
ah oui j'ai joué j'ai un souvenir
intéressant
j'avais joué j'avais vu qu'on trouve
bâti
c'était avant non c'était c'était la
dernière ronde je crois dernière ronde
du championnat de France de Blitz
c'était à Nice en 2011 je crois
2011 ou 2012 je crois que c'est en 2011
Nice championnat de France de Blitz
dernière ronde et je faisais plutôt un
bon tournoi donc pour être tableau un
contre bac pro dernière ongle c'est
quand même que j'avais fait un bon
tournoi et bah qui lui par contre il
était en tête du tournoi et en fait il
allait gagner l'événement et il y avait
Sébastien Mazet qui était juste derrière
juste derrière
backi trans tournoi et il attendait la
faute de Baki pour pouvoir le dépasser
et en fait il se trouve que j'ai
commencé j'avais les Noirs donc c'était
une slave il m'a bien bien bien massacré
et à la fin de la partie et ben la
commence à 3 + 2 et on est arrivé à une
position où on avait tous les deux trois
secondes à la pendule donc trois
secondes à la pendule sur l'incrément
c'était du Bullet voilà et il avait une
position où sur mon aile dame il est
plus rien il m'a tout mangé qui m'a vu
tout mangé et il avait des pions qui
avaient et de l'autre côté j'avais
toutes les pièces sur son roi pour le
mater et donc j'avais très peu de chance
de le matin mais
bon je t'ai foutu donc j'essayais quoi
et en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
c'est que un moment donné j'ai deux
échecs possibles et j'avais l'impression
en fait j'avais l'impression en fait que
j'avais la nul quand je voulais et quand
j'ai fait échec qu'il avait deux cas
d'accentrois il y a une case où tu en as
dans ma tête c'était nul et l'autre cas
ce que j'ai pas calculé et en fait il
allait sur la case
ou il y avait un match en deux coups et
je l'ai pas du tout regardé parce qu'en
fait je pensais que je pensais que enfin
c'est tellement évident que pas bon que
je veux pas calculer et il l'a fait et
du coup j'ai paniqué j'ai fait un coup
au hasard alors que j'avais pas tant de
coup contre Étienne Macron et au final
je l'ai pas fait et
j'ai perdu la partie voilà rapidement
pour pour H3 c'est un blender on voit la
courbe on voit tout ça mais en fait
c'est pas si débile parce qu'en fait si
jamais je mange le fou je perds E4 la
tour ok si je fais ça intermédiaire ton
point et je mange là bah il mange là
donc c'est pas si débile en fait mais
apparemment il y a un dingue B3
intermédiaire qui a l'air de faire très
mal
pour
pour Magnus parce qu'ici en fait après
dame B3 il va se passer quoi si je fais
tu reprends tu reprends et si je prends
là et qui prend là
j'ai ça
OK
suivant
et ben je prends
pas mal en fait voyons un petit peu en
fait il aurait pu faire directement d'un
point d'apprendre H3 mais en fait il a
fait d'abord dame bet3 à chaque pour
décaler le roi et avoir ce petit tempo à
la fin Magnus machine donc là c'est
c'est gagnant donc mais nous on voit on
voit la tête des joueurs on voit la
courbe enfin le le machin qui bouge là
on voit la jauge et on va vous prendre
un schtroumpdi mais qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait la disjoncter mais en fait c'était
pas si débile mais voilà malheureusement
pour Fabi il a raté une pointe tactique
qui a fait qu'il a perdu qu'il a perdu
un truc donc impossible à voir ben non
tu vois la preuve que Magnus l'a vu mais
Magnus c'est un des meilleurs enfin
c'est même le meilleur joueur du monde
actuel donc
ce serait surprenant qui rate ce genre
de tactique
donc voilà maintenant il va gagner il a
un peu non plus en plus depuis on avance
il y a des pions qui sont quand même
assez assez moches chez les chez les
Noirs il y a le roi qui répond ouvert
cette position elle est gagnante assez
facilement normalement pour
pour Magnus
non en fait c'est difficile de comparer
les meilleurs joueurs du monde vous
savez comment comment comparer Magnus
avec avec Instant offre avec Fischer
avec à l'équipe enfin comment tu comment
tu veux c'est un peu compliqué de chaque
champion à son époque le moyen qu'ils
avaient c'est dur de comparer mais cette
Magnus actuellement c'est ouf
quoi enfin personne vraiment personne
personne qui bat quoi c'est juste c'est
le monstre du circuit commun
donc actuellement c'est sûr et peut-être
même le meilleur avant de tous les temps
dans les muscade et d'ailleurs il y
avait dans une interview
Caravana qui avait annoncé enfin il
avait dit que il avait sûrement
la génération la plus forte de tous les
temps en fait alors prendre à si cela
sans calculer ça a l'air chaud il y a
plein d'échec
donc j'ai pas envie de prendre de
risques faire plein d'échecs ma venue
s'il va mettre son roi ici il va faire
des échecs il va essayer de ne se
mobiliser avant de passer l'attaque
mais c'est vrai que quand tu vois la
génération de Fabi il est né en 92 et
que tu vois qu'en 92 il y avait des
joueurs comme
ouais mais en vrai c'est la elle est
trop dure la
la génération de génération monstrueuse
c'est un faux débat
ouais c'est compliqué c'est compliqué en
fait c'est des bases sont un peu dignes
aussi ouais c'est un peu difficile en
fait tous ces toutes ces comment dire
c'est débat en fait c'est dur de
comparer
mais où on chaque joueur dans son temps
a été le meilleur à chaque fois vous
voyez car c'est pas grave quand il quand
il faisait son règne c'était le mec le
genre que personne pouvait hâte quoi bon
Rami qu'il est arrivé là-bas dessus mais
de manière générale castorale c'était
vraiment le meilleur joueur tous les
temps quoi à son époque tu avais aussi
Fischer
malheureusement Fischer il était un peu
spécial comme joueur donc c'était
pas si facile au final
il a pas assez joué en fait
etc mais bon c'est vraiment difficile de
juger en fait on peut pas juger je pense
trop compliqué
pour le Gard
sur
[Musique]
tout ça mais bon c'est dur de juger
vraiment chacun à son époque pas évident
quoi
après la nouvelle génération des Indiens
Arméniens
les Ouzbeks aussi les Iraniens tu as une
génération qui arrive qui est
monstrueuse
les les Pragues les gamers et les Gazi
et puis encore plein d'autres c'est
génération qui est aussi hâte de cette
offre
qui est là aussi c'est c'est
là en fait
carwana il a aucune chance il a jamais
eu de chance en fait du monde et
maintenant Caravana il pourra peut-être
être champion du monde à ce quartier ne
joue plus
mais en la présence de Magnus
normalement je vois personne poisson qui
le détrôner quoi vraiment sur un match
c'est trop dur quoi
très bientôt est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on aille voir un peu ce qui se passe
à côté
alors je vois que ça fait nul ça a fait
entre so et Firo on ira voir après
comment ça a fait nul mais ça fait nul
donc on va rester là dessus du coup
ça fait
[Musique]
pas beaucoup de très de ouais de joueurs
allemands il n'a pas énormément mais il
y a quand même une génération
intéressante d'allemand qui arrive aussi
avec les veines les je sais plus où
leurs noms mais ils sont
4 5 à 2650 des jeunes
qui sont
ultra solides
et franchement
c'est une belle génération mais bon
c'est pas une génération comparable à
celle des Indiens qui ont 5 ans de moins
et sans points de plus quoi c'est pas
pas la même
van
c'est ma musc qui est parti la partie
vous savez qu'on a on a une on a une une
un décalage de une minute par rapport à
twitch et la partie qu'on a ici c'est
pour ça que tu as Marius est parti
on a plus sa caméra ce qui est parti
mais ne vous inquiétez pas il va revenir
pour la deuxième partie
la colère aussi exactement puis il y en
a d'autres encore
en fait pour
pour ramener les pions là va être long
et ça sent bon pas besoin de ça mais
juste pour dire que c'est juste trop dur
sur ça je fais ça
probablement
c'est terminé allez Magnus qui gagne
cette première partie du match
pardon donc je vous rappelle que il y a
quatre parties de 15 + 3 dans ce match
donc on a déjà eu une nulle entre so et
Ali resa et une victoire de Magnus
contre carwana donc on va avoir du coup
la deuxième partie qui va commencer du 5
minutes donc je propose de faire une
petite page de pub et on se revoit dans
5 minutes pour la deuxième partie de ces
demi-finales de ce match merci beaucoup
magicien pour ton petit message très
sympa
pas encore en tout cas c'est pas du tout
dans mes prétentions ni dans
ni dans mon programme mais on en
reparlera éventuellement dans quelques
années si jamais je me rapproche de 2014
mais bon ça encore à voir c'est pas du
tout au programme pour l'instant une
petite page de pub rapidos et je reviens
dans 5 minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis de retour maintenant voilà avec
les joueurs qui se sont mis en place et
qui vont commencer
la deuxième partie alors j'ai toujours
pas la partie qui s'affiche sur forcesco
mais ça va arriver avec pour l'instant
d'ailleurs je me suis trompé dans les
points c'est pas du tout mis les bons
pourquoi parce que j'ai pas mis les bons
à ce que je suis un demeuré ou est-ce
que
je suis un débile os j'ai l'impression
[Musique]
donc Magnus a bien sûr un point
donc je vais faire un peu nappe dans
ses résultats qui sont actualisés
et ici
ok je viens de comprendre mon petit
problème
OK
on va rester comme ça alors Magnus qui
pour l'instant gagne 1-0 dans ce match
et la partie qui a commencé à l'instant
en tout cas j'ai la partie ici sous les
yeux et les temps qui vont aussi arriver
dans quelques instants donc généralement
il y a un petit délai de d'environ une
minute et ça va comment ça Magnus qui
mène 1-0 il y a quatre parties dans ce
match en priori 4
mais des fois il y en a moins que ça ça
peut arriver que trois parties par
exemple c'est malus venait à gagner
encore une fois la partie ça fait 2-0 et
après un match nul sur la troisième
partie ça fait match terminé parce que
pourra jamais rattraper ma venue sur une
seule partie
donc ça va commencer à un instant car on
a blanc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'ouverture
à votre avis ça va être quoi ça va être
une espagnole
ça va être plutôt avec des quatre une
Nimzo
un grand
autre chose
moi je vois bien ah bah tiens ces quatre
j'allais dire une italienne
mais
Carla qui joue C4 G6
donc ces quatre G6 E4
et donc on risque peut-être de tomber
dans une sorte
de
destin bien avoir un peu comment
se joue
se joue la partie
donc 4 qu'est-ce qui peut jouer plein de
choses
c'est 5 pour ne pas jouer une éternelle
comment est-ce que va jouer ma musique
là ça dépend vraiment de quelle
stratégie il veut quelle structure
Magnus va vouloir adopter
donc ici je peux j'ai foulées
ici il y aurait eu 5 probablement
qui fait pas plaisir
donc si ça va pour aussi jouer c'est
simple pour entre guillemets empêcher
des quatre
j'en ai pas parlé parce que je pensais
pas qu'elle allait faire ça mais E5
cavalier H5 genre position ça existe
toujours ça existe c'est extrêmement
bizarre mais voilà c'est le coup et des
fois il y a des vents avec G4 ou le
cavalier pour partir
soit f4d le 6 soit en G7 et c'est assez
marrant et en fait c'est pollution quand
vraiment les blancs essaient de réfuter
les Noirs entre cabane en H5 et ben très
souvent
et ben ils se prennent un mur parce
qu'en fait au final c'est pas si clair
et je pense que peut-être une meilleure
moyenne ce système c'est de jouer
normalement aux échecs et au final tu
vas rester qu'un cavaler mal placé ici
bon par exemple peut-être là faire eux
prendre des 6 et sortir les pièces
peut-être c'est un bon petit choix pour
essayer de juste
sortir les pièces normalement et à
partir de folie
parce que les coups comme G4 après je
pense spécialiste mais de un j'ai
cavaliers 7
bon c'est pas beau mais bon voilà mais
après qu'avec le 7 je pourrais me
recycler mais le fait d'avoir G4 c'est
que maintenant et sur G4 il y a aussi
peut-être des idées avec prise là aussi
tu prends là je prends là donc j'ai
quand même plein de pions pour les
pièces tu as ouvert partout sur case
blanche c'est pas si évident que ça
donc hop la vie F4 est fou H6 jouer
instant donc c'est une position qui est
extrêmement bizarre quand même le pion
F4 qui est en danger
immédiatement et il faut défendre il a
pas l'air très content car voilà de
cette position
parce que c'est pas un truc qui va
regarder
récemment et en tout cas malus qui
essaie de surprendre à chaque fois c'est
une ouverture extrêmement bizarre mais
qui qui se joue
[Musique]
les quatre pions ça jouent encore quand
même pas trop trop déjà de base l'est
indienne à haut niveau ça joue pas trop
alors la Capion c'est bien
[Musique]
franchement
ça fait ça fait extrêmement peur pour
pour Fabi ça habille qui qui pourrait se
prendre un 2-0 imminent
si personne la famille ça fait 2-0
ça fait
peur quand même
il a pas l'air content vous voyez
en 8 coups il y a déjà moins bien avec
les Blancs
c'est
assez ouf à ce niveau là d'être en
préparation très très tôt moi je vois la
jauge et je vous dis que apparemment le
coup F4 ce n'est pas du tout un bon coup
donc on est même juste on est au
cinquième coup au cinquième coup et
Fabiano il sait pas quoi faire il est
complètement en priori et il fait
mauvais coup sur le mauvais coup
c'est ouf quand même
moi je connais pas bon ok c'est pas mon
répertoire j'y connais rien puis moi je
suis amateur mais Caravana au 8e coup
elle se trouve là dedans ça me ça me
choque un petit peu quand même
ça me choque un petit peu qu'il ne soit
pas au courant de tout ce qui se passe
là et Magnus
très confiant
en plus il est vraiment
[Musique]
enfin on a comme ça il le joue un peu à
la cool quand même je pense et si je
peux faire une ouverture un peu un peu
marrante je pense qu'il va pas se gêné
parce que c'est pas un tournoi officiel
il y a pas il y a pas d'éloé etc donc du
coup je pense qu'il est content Magnus
de jouer des positions un peu marrantes
comme ça un peu du commun où il y a
beaucoup moins de théorie
et je pense qu'il est assez content de
sa position en tout cas bon la position
est clairement en talent
dans le moins 1,50
je pense que maintenant il subit encore
la forme psychologique de Magnus
oui peut-être en fait Magnus le problème
c'est qu'il a il en a un ascendant
contre tout le monde sauf contre les
petits jeunes
qui s'en foutent complètement et qui
veulent juste essayer de
[Musique]
créer de créer leur place si vous voulez
dans le haut niveau donc un petit Prague
un petit goûter ils vont peut-être
perdre mais il s'en foutent ils veulent
juste jouer alors qu'en fait les autres
joueurs au niveau souvent
ces cartes scènes
il est injouable
c'est dur quand un jour comme ça qui à
chaque fois te la colle tout la colle de
la colle
après c'est pas vrai c'est quand même
que
plein de fois
même vu il y avait un speech il y a un
an c'était l'année dernière un speed
chasses ou Magnus avait adopté une
famille quoi
10 parties d'acide avait gagné
Magnus contre carwana c'est des Blitz
certes mais tu perds des parties
d'affilée quand même
et ton moral vient prend un coup quand
même hein et même si c'est des monstres
et qui ont tous de 1800 Hello
qui descend vite quand même donc
intéressant quoi
après je pense aussi quand même je pense
aussi quand même qu'il y a il peut y
avoir aussi un peu de fatigue au niveau
de cette Caravana qui sort de la Coupe
du monde
mais c'est quand même tapé Carson aussi
il va gagner la coupe du monde donc il
allait encore plus loin mais ce joueur
là qui sont quand même aller jusqu'au
bout de la compétition ils sont allés en
finale et carwana qui est arrivé qui
arrivait 3e d'ailleurs qui a qui qui a
juste le dernier jour possible de ce
tournoi ben pendant pendant plus d'un
mois ils ont joué tous les jours d'échec
quasiment c'est enfin c'est fatiguant
qu'il n'est pas des lots en jeu sur un
tournoi ils sont chez eux ils sont chez
eux à la maison et je suis sur internet
il y a pas des lots c'est pas un vrai
hello c'est pas des vélos lents rapides
ils ont les lot de chasse comme tu vois
mais qui est en jeu mais il y a pas de
doute des lots on devrait c'est normal
c'est pas un tournoi IRL
c'est vraiment combien de temps à vous
atteint le ennemi aussi quand même de
l'eau avec vous pris la première année
de pratique
alors là tu peux me tutoyer j'ai
l'impression que je suis un petit vieux
et bah là j'ai actuellement 33 ans et je
suis passé maître cette année
il y a même à peu près un petit mois que
je suis passé maître donc c'est tout
récent
et donc combien de temps j'ai mis
beaucoup beaucoup de temps c'est dur et
je suis pas le plus gros bosseur en plus
du monde donc voilà et la première année
de pratique alors moi j'ai commencé
quand on était tout petit
j'ai commencé à 7 ans
quand j'avais 7 ans
très brillant tu vois donc au début je
suis resté 1000 pendant très longtemps
pour plusieurs années j'avais 1000 je
comprenais pas bien j'étais tout petit
et puis voilà quoi donc je suis pas un
bon exemple du tout
après ça dépend vous dans le chat vous
êtes plus grand donc vous avez
généralement vous comprenez quand même
plus vite qu'un enfant de 7 ans
au tout début et donc vous progressez
plus vite c'est normal
moi je suis pas du tout une référence à
ce niveau là
c'est une Master Class Magnus Master
Class là il vaut ouvrir la position pour
amener les tours toutes les pièces
noires qui viennent bien placé à part ce
cavalier là qui va se recycler mais là
si vous regardez les pièces blanches le
roi qui était Rocket c'est c'est
horrible cette position complètement
dans le monde des milles j'en sais rien
il y en a beaucoup en France il y en a
déjà
je dirais peut-être une centaine
même pas peut-être même pas je sais pas
mais dans le monde il y en a même
plusieurs milliers mais bon
avec un autre joueur le travail avec un
voilà ouais ouais c'est le bleu on va
peut-être pas
ouvrir ce débat
dans la 50 à la retraite depuis des
échecs depuis 17 ans ok moi je suis un
bon exemple je suis 1200 depuis 21 ans
je suis un modèle de résilience ben moi
c'est un peu pareil pour le titre de ami
ça fait depuis 2016 que j'avais toutes
mes normes pour passer amis et je suis
passé émis en 2023 vous imaginez alors
vous avez tout mon élo faisait comme ça
j'arrive jamais à partir de 1400 et lots
mais c'est un peu le même genre que toi
ce week sauf que bon j'ai plus de Lomé
j'ai 32 ans et je compte me mettre aux
échecs sérieusement cette année en club
je dois viser pour avoir un objectif
viable pour un départ je n'arrive pas à
me faire arriver et j'ai peur de voir
trop gros
alors déjà tu peux te fixer plusieurs
objectifs mon objectif déjà sur
le court terme et un sur le long terme
il y a un truc que c'est important c'est
que le hello cheescom et le hello que tu
auras en vrai complètement différent les
jeux sont différents eux-mêmes donc
c'est pas parce que tu as un gros hello
justom que tu vas avoir un gros hello en
vrai ça n'a rien à voir
dans tous les cas il faut progresser il
veut progresser et en progressant ton
orienté naturellement et il y a pas
mieux pour progresser que s'inscrire
dans un club d'échec pour rencontrer des
gens voir des gens faire de la
compétition et aussi éventuellement
faire des cours il y a des cours de
groupe etc ça dépend où tu habites dans
tous les cas
franchir les portes d'un club c'est le
mieux que tu puisses faire pour prouver
sur des chèques c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment important
je sais pas où c'est j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas il faut que tu que tu
joues en club c'est c'est
très très bien c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
et mais moi je te conseillerais de pas
te mettre trop la tête d'un objectif
parce que quand tu vois trop quand tu
vois trop trop loin trop haut et ben des
fois tu te trompes dans ce blexis c'est
pas clair avec toi-même et tu es déçu et
tu arrêtes d'échec etc donc moi je te
dirai juste fais-toi plaisir José
chèques et essaie de juste prendre du
plaisir de progresser tranquillement et
tu verras après quand tu seras un peu
plus fort quand tu auras plus
d'expérience tu pourras peut-être plus
tard voir un objectif viable mais pour
l'instant tu découvres un peu tout juste
fais-toi plaisir et c'est le règle
numéro 1 voilà
speedrun rush kit bah ouais tu vois en
fait si tu si tu mets trop d'habitude
dans la tête et ben tu peux être complet
et arrêter et voilà et c'est pas du tout
ce que tu cherches tu veux juste
progresser donc dans la bulle de
progression et on joue et on se fait
plaisir
c'est tout
mais nous allons commencer avec deux
amis donc je sais qu'on va vouloir
chaque année être dessus ouais ça c'est
ça c'est déjà un flexif intéressant par
rapport à
je vous laisse bonne soirée maigret et
bonne soirée aussi à pion qui pousse
c'est sûr je pense que je pense que je
vais me qualifier
je crois bien qu'aucune personne qui
sait mieux aux échecs étant
gel là aussi
j'ai pas bien compris ton message
j'arrive pas à comprendre ton message
ah pardon c'est bon voilà je suis
fatigué j'arrive pas à dormir un message
élite moi je connais un grand maître qui
a commencé échec très tard genre à 20
ans il est passé grand maître à peu près
26 ans 24 ans
j'en connais un mais c'est rare
extrêmement rare c'était il y a très
longtemps
salut sans dire le Baron Noir salut à
tous
ah tu restes ok j'ai mal lu j'ai arrêté
à
20 après mon premier Open c'est pourtant
eu un super état c'était trop dur pour
moi je me suis consacré un truc moins
tuant ouais bah c'est vrai que les
échecs c'est
psychologiquement ça peut être très très
dur et c'est vrai que des fois quand on
joue aux échecs on se rend pas compte de
l'impact émotionnel psychologique qu'une
partie est sec peut avoir sur nous c'est
c'est juste ouf et je pense que vraiment
les noms joueurs d'échec du mal à nous
comprendre
en tout cas moi des fois ça m'arrive de
faire un Open de faire un truc et que le
soir ben je vois des amis qui jouent pas
aux échecs
et je suis dégoûté j'ai perdu ma partie
j'ai fait de la merde bah au final vous
savez quoi ils comprennent pas c'est
qu'un jeu tu as perdu c'est qu'un jeu
bah non c'est pas qu'un jeu quoi tu peux
pas dire ça avec un genre d'échec tu
peux pas le dire c'est qu'un jeu tu peux
pas lui dire ça c'est pas possible juste
là tu
veux mourir quoi c'est tu me dis que
c'est qu'un jeu en fait en vrai ça se
rappelle quoi c'est pas possible de dire
ça on peut pas dire ça à un genre
d'échec pas possible
une partie importante c'est pas grave tu
verras la prochaine non je dis pas ça
il y a plein de choses comme ça aussi
que les joueurs peuvent pas comprendre
tout simplement
un petit peu drogué ouais c'est déjà que
c'est un peu une preuve en quelque sorte
un truc qu'on aime tous c'est que on met
beaucoup d'énergie que d'intérêt
là-dedans et du coup les gens
comprennent pas que pas de perdre une
partie
après ça dépend bien sur la partie mais
bon compliqué
il est hyper fort il le sait et c'est
voilà c'est
encore tu l'as pas vu par une partie en
elle a une partie vraiment avec enjeu je
pense que c'est pire donc bon je le sais
pas une partie enfin jamais vraiment
parlé avec lui après une défaite sur un
vrai tournoi mais
les meilleurs joueurs du monde
n'accepte beaucoup moins la défaite
parce que pour eux c'est quand même dur
par une partie normalement voilà filou
on peut aller voir fille où on n'a pas
encore suivi là dans ce cette deuxième
partie on va aller voir de suite merci
beaucoup trop petit message daynamar
et on a Fillon qu'il y avait noir dans
cette pollution donc ça c'est une
pollution italienne si je me trompe pas
je me suis trompé
se tromper complètement
c'est une position qui est plus ou moins
transpose dans une italienne quand même
la structure en tout cas c'est ça
et d'un petit parent F4 je fais un peu
vite pour rattraper un peu le retard
qu'on a firu qui est un peu mal au temps
mais qui a une position assez
intéressante avec la paire de fou
donc là à voir si je peux pas manger à
manger en le 5 parce que si je peux
manger 5 ça peut être pas mal pour les
noirs
opposé mais une tour quand même assez
bien placée et là je peux pas faire
tourner le tacos il faut prendre vite
donc ce pion il est pas facile à
défendre intéressant en tout cas pour
firou qui peut pousser un peu cette
position j'aime beaucoup la pollution de
Fléron ici je pense qu'il peut faire
quelque chose
mais rebonjour la peinture
c'est normal de pas accepter de perdre
parce que pour toi c'est tellement
d'investissement c'est tellement et puis
en plus il y a beaucoup aux échecs de
comment dire d'abord propre par rapport
à par rapport à ce qu'on fait quoi et
pas une partie c'est du genre
plus dur d'échec c'est d'avoir une
potion gagnante oui
quelqu'un aimait perdre
pas être en club pour y participer oui
mais peu il y en a peu tout Nolan parce
qu'en fait ça tourne là c'est pas
homologué ça veut dire qu'ils comptent
pas pour le classement si
la Fédération veut que le tournoi compte
pour le classement le classement et
l'eau donc quasiment tout le temps que
tu vas avoir et ben il faut que le toit
soit homologué ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'il compte pour le devant c'est à dire
qu'il faut être
il faut avoir une licence donc en fait
voilà après tu as plusieurs licences tu
as l'essence A et B je sais qu'en France
A et B et sens B elle coûte rien
et ça permet rapide donc faire un petit
rapide ou un blitz de temps en temps ça
coûte 5 euros par an
et tu joues ce que tu veux quoi donc ça
va on n'est pas non plus
à 5 euros
après la licence A qui permet de faire
les tournois partie lente par contre ça
c'est plus cher alors je sais pas le
prix exact environ 50 euros je crois
50 euros et tu joues tout ton masque que
tu veux par an voilà
après je me trompe peut-être même que
c'est à peu près ça les prix mais je
suis plus trop en ce moment donc je sais
plus et moi ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai pas payé ma licence d'ailleurs
ça veut dire peut-être
effectivement que vous avez froid ça
peut être une idée pour pas enfin tant
qu'à perdre tant qu'à perdre le cavalier
on donne comme ça mais après je fais
quand même ça c'est vrai que c'est le
meilleur version celle là avec le pion
ici que le pion je suis d'accord avec
toi
donc c'est peut-être pas mal du tout il
y a eu tour des un du coup il a pas
mangé en B5 allez ça il garde la tension
comment on défense bien
il est pas descendant en fait il est pas
descendable ce pion que ouais j'ai pas
attendu
il veut pas il veut un truc comme ça
s'il faut prendre ça ouais marrant si tu
reprends je sens pareil c'est là
de septembre jusqu'à septembre donc tu
la prends en août ta licence ben dommage
tu vas reprendre en septembre à
septembre donc voilà
un coup de sport les joueurs acceptent
le fait que certains autres gens sont
plus forts que ouais c'est sincèrement
que jamais vu c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que d'échec
on se sauve on se surestime tous dès
qu'on perd contre un joueur qui qu'on
considère moins fort que nous ben on se
sévère tu peux ressentir la faute qu'il
accepte simplement
c'est vrai je suis d'accord avec toi
la gamme de Wesley
pixel
vous la voyez pas
mon club hier 49 ok je pensais que
c'était un peu un peu plus cher que ça
49 et 9 ok bon c'est un ça m'a l'air
honnête et comment vas-tu
comment vas-tu
mon grand ami de Belgique
ok si ça a été joué trois six
et un petit problème ici j'ai
l'impression que les blancs
[Musique]
peuvent poser des problèmes avec des
pions vous voyez par le front prise
prise là voilà à l'envers je sais pas si
le noir il faut le manger intermédiaire
ici échec et prise là présent et quand
même si possible je prends là il prend
là en B2 c'est pas clair dans tous les
cas dans tous les cas
dans tous les cas c'est compliqué mais
je pense qu'ici les raisins il peut
créer une une surprise
en gardant la partie
et
je sais pas si il va réussir à aller
jusqu'au bout est-ce que vous voulez
voir la partie de Magnus parce que là il
est en finale il reste plus beaucoup de
pièces je pense qu'on peut aller voir
rapidement Magnus et revenir après sur
un livraison pour voir un petit peu où
il en est
alors ici
Magnus elle est noire
regardez bien et il a un pion de plus
net mais c'est vrai que le roi blanc est
assez actif
et ce qui compenserait un petit peu pour
le pion de retard
et en plus il faut défendre ce cavalier
la question comme 5 il peut y avoir roi
E4 et ce pion il a un peu dur à défendre
je peux toujours faire E5 voilà et voilà
et après je suis pas sûr vous voyez
droit qui peut monter là bas prendre ce
pion même la cavalier qui peut être un
jour de manière manger aussi et puis en
5 c'est pas si c'est pas si c'est pas si
c'est clair et en fait je sais pas ici à
la place de faire
de faire E5 c'est simple c'est un peu le
même genre en fait surtout on va
toujours être un petit peu un peu faible
et je sais pas peut-être ça ça c'est pas
trop
comment faire
il y a un jeu qui avait ici directement
c'est pousser les pions c'est un petit
peu quand même
les noirs qui vont activer les rois
alors est-ce que est-ce que
[Musique]
si c'est un goût alors j'aime pas trop
le 6 mais j'ai empêche un peu cavaler 5
par exemple
qui peut être embêtant j'ai pas trop
envie de perdre ce petit pion c'est 7
donc parce que j'ai vraiment envie de
jouer
aussi sous pas la position aller à
à compliquer c'est incroyable il va
contre mes idées je pense qu'il m'écoute
en son dans son oreillette Magnus
il m'écoute et il veut faire tous les
coups que je dis qu'ils sont pas bon
génial sur cavaler des cinq esquive de
jouer alors
ce serait une perte de temps quand même
de base
bien sûr cavaler des dessins
qui empêche roi des 6 je doute que ma
venue va jouer roi des 7 quand même ça
serait
ce serait je pense
le jeu tiens il vient de faire
logique donc qu'est-ce qu'il a en tête
mamie ici est-ce que ici il veut faire
est-ce que vous voyez un coup ici
ca va le 5 c'est ce que je regardais
aussi
cavalue 5 attaque C4 et sur cavaler
c'est 7 roi des 7
j'attaque là et là c'est intéressant ça
le roi des 6 sera encore échec et après
je viens défendre alors que du coup si
je fais roi D7 j'attaque là et là et Roy
F5 pour envahir comment proposer c'est
aussi intéressant mais je sais pas
peut-être le temps de défendre peut-être
ça va j'en sais rien
moi c'est plus d'avis allez manger des
pions quand même mais ouais je sens
qu'elle a aussi pas mal
salut à toi
il s'en fout complètement du pion en C7
et après ici après le coup qui avait les
P4 mais il menace de manger à deux mais
surtout en fait il me lance quand même
les trois cavalent et ça par contre ça
fait peur
donc là il vient de je B3 donc c'est une
erreur nous on le voit on le sait on
voit la jauge on voit le point
d’interrogation eux ils le voient pas
tout ça donc là on peut imaginer qu'elle
va les prendre à deux et derrière qui a
l'air de faire le taf
et sur un 6 sur qu'elle avait 5
maintenant ce qu'on joue à 6
parce que la grande question parce qu'en
fait plus j'échange les pions
plus j'ai des chances de faire nul avec
le camp qui a le moins de pions donc
j'ai pas trop envie avec ma news la
peine noire de donner tous les pions
parce qu'on a l'impression que
car voilà pourrait un jour sans sortir
pas sûr qu'il a envie eux qui va te
prendre un de il y a lui qui avait le
dessin il y a eu à 5 à 5 malins il rend
le pion recettes voyez à ce niveau là
c'est pas des pions qui sont importants
c'est vraiment le fait de se créer des
plans passer le fait de jouer actif tout
le temps et ici à 5 l'idée c'est de
faire
manger lui et écrire passer qui serait
très très loin
du roi blanc très très loin du cavalier
etc donc c'est vraiment son idée et
c'est c'est vraiment hyper hyper fort ce
qu'il a fait et sur la 5 il y a pas
beaucoup de coups c'est très très dur de
manière défendre le pion en métro je
vois aucun coup
je vois aucun coup
pour défendre puis on met trois et
Cavana qui est encore le sourire
non généralement quand il est quand il
joue pas bien il a il sourit pas trop
enfin comme tout ça vous savez on est
même pas perdre mais non non c'est pas
un joueur qui sourit beaucoup hyper
comme d'autres car certaines non plus
c'est pas genre qui est sur le quantité
j'en connais pas des joueurs qui sont
quand ils perdent peut-être Prague quand
il a pas de compte car c'est en finale
de la Coupe du monde mais bon il avait
déjà fait
vous comprenez pas personne n'aime
perdre personne va sourire
après ok il y a des gens il y a des gens
qui sont faire play et qui peuvent voilà
mais bon c'est pas la dire quand même
que on va sourire etc à ce niveau là les
joueurs ils sont professionnels elles
veulent pas trop quand même
sérieux
alors je vais de mon côté regardez un
peu ce qui se passe chez Spirou
je vais au sport il est un petit peu la
finale parce qu'on peut pas voir les
deux malheureusement
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il y a deux pions de plus
Fiero qui
ah mais il y a deux pions plus mais
peut-être un seul en fait
je vous montre rapidement la partie
juste pour que vous puissiez
voir un peu les deux parties en même
temps malheureusement
après on voit que les joueurs sont
partis
du coup on va rester là encore une
minute voir ce qui s'est passé pour
terminer cette partie après on ira voir
après on ira voir la suite et Magnus qui
va gagner 2-0 cette partie je regarderai
des points je prends là il s'en fout
complètement en fait
prise puis on passait ici
et encore une fois ce pion qui veut pas
bouger qui avait dit qu'il bouge pas non
plus parce qu'il est il est bloqué à la
défense de spion B3 c'est encore une
masse leur place en finale franchement
j'étais content de perdre une carpoque
en simultané bah oui c'est pas pareil
moi je dois je le vois pas comme une
compétition
deuxième point sur deux et on va voir la
partie maintenant de fil rouge qui a des
blancs dans cette partie donc là un pion
d'avance je vais vous mettre le score le
score
un jour
des deux joueurs
le score des deux joueurs 0,5 05 il y a
une partie de jouer contrairement à
Magnus ou il y en avait déjà deux
et après tout c'est 8 ici on va sûrement
jouer roi F7 il y a pas de 35 Combes
aussi faire Toro 2 il faut descendre ce
petit four
comment est-ce qu'on va s'y prendre
logique pour activer
le roi
comment est-ce qu'on passe j'ai un pion
de plus je pourrais pousser mon pion de
B où me poncer
mais vous voyez quand même la position
c'est que le reposer et
généralement c'est position favorise
l'annule mais ici ce qu'on voit au delà
de ça c'est que
le roi noir est un peu faible par
rapport au roi blanc
il y a des raisons un peu de maths et
aussi même fout des cartes qui peut être
une idée assez intéressante avec l'idée
plus tard une fois que je fais échec roi
là il faut des quatre et essayer de
pousser j'ai 5 pour taper avec mon fou
et ma tour sur la case G7 et ça peut
être une idée assez intéressante qu'on
peut essayer d'exploiter
donc firou a plus que 11 secondes à la
pendule
et en face il y a une 40 pour pour les
noirs
donc une 40 pour les Noirs contre 11
secondes pour des blancs c'est il y a
plus beaucoup de temps mais c'est une
potion qui se joue quand même assez
facilement avec les Blancs qui peut pas
faire quand même de grosses gaffe et
perdre cette position c'est impossible
donc le temps il est pas si important
que ça pour moi c'est pas vraiment
révélateur de dire que firou a plus que
11 secondes pour moi c'est pas si grave
que ça vu l'état de la position en plus
sur eux c'est un très très bon genre de
Bullet donc je me fais pas trop de
soucis pour lui au niveau du temps qu'il
lui reste peut-être qu'il trouvera pas
le gain parce qu'elle n'a pas tant la
pendule mais en tout cas il va pas
gâcher je le vois pas bien fait
difficile à évaluer
mais bon
tu sais que tu perds pas quoi c'est
impossible on a vu partir fâché
donc voir un peu ce qu'il a fait est-ce
qu'il a
ce qu'il a fait l'un
parce qu'ils ont fait nul je pense pas
qu'ils aient fait nul avec si peu de
temps ça m'a l'air assez incroyable
ah il échange des pièces du coup nul ça
peut clairement être possible je pensais
pas que sur vous allez faire nul dans
une position
c'est pas clair encore
et ça fait nul direct ok donc il y a
quand même tout liquide dans une
position avec un pion de plus essayer de
pousser un peu je pense qu'il s'est
rendu compte que il y avait absolument
rien en fait final et il a décidé du
coup de faire match nul donc du coup
qui résumé Magnus qui mène 2-0 dans ce
minimat pendant que les deux joueurs
saut Wesley et ailleurs
ont deux nul alors compteur donc on va
aller au bout de l'argent il y aura
encore deux parties minimum entre so et
Ali resa alors que Magnus s'il fait nul
dès la prochaine partie et bien il sera
automatiquement qualifié pour la finale
du du Japan chest tour
de de fin août parce qu'il y a quand
même c'est la cinquième édition
donc voilà voilà
est-ce qu'on serait pas une petite pause
de 5 minutes avant la troisième partie
ce sera du coup probablement l'avant
dernière pause de la journée pour moi et
donc je vous dis à de suite je reviens
dans 5 minutes pour le dénouement un
petit peu de de ces deux matchs qui sont
très très intéressants je vous dis à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà je suis de retour avec les joueurs
qui sont pas là il y a que moi qui est
là et vous bien sûr je n'oublie pas vous
êtes là je suis là les joueurs ne sont
pas encore là on voit le beau canapé de
Magnus a bien rangé comme il faut
et
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ce soit qui est pas
encore arrivé chez lui
et du coup nous bah on est prêt pour
cette troisième partie les joueurs qui
tombent pas encore installés ça va
reprendre dans quelques instants donc le
score on est à 2-0 pour pour Magnus
carlsel contre Cavana et Manu aura les
blancs dans cette troisième partie donc
si il perd pas cette partie et bien il
se qualifie pour la finale directement
donc ça va déjà une belle option pour
Magnus dans ce champion de chaise tour
et caméra ici on va aller voir si on
peut voir un petit peu les caméras de
l'autre jour on voit que Ali resa est
prêt il est là alors que sous Wesley et
ben il n'est pas là je vais vous mettre
à jour les points des joueurs ça sera un
peu mieux comme ça vous avez les joueurs
qui ont un point et je pense que pour la
troisième partie
si vous le voulez bien va rester sur la
partie raisin
contre contre saut parce que Magnus on
va dire qu'il est quasiment qualifié
déjà il avait deux sur deux il manque
deux parties à faire et à moins que
Magnus perde deux fois d'affilée et ben
il devra jouer il doit jouer un
départage mais bon
je pense pas que ma muse perte de partie
d'affilée contre Caravana c'est possible
toujours mais la côte elle est pas très
élevée à mon avis du coup le Mac plus
intéressant à suivre serait le match là
de so Wesley contre
deux parties sont à
deux nuls donc du coup je pense c'est
plus intéressant de suivre ce match là
il y a plus d'enjeux que dans l'autre ou
les dés sont quasiment déjà jetés
donc voilà après ça reste mon avis je
sais pas si vous êtes d'accord avec moi
si vous voulez suivre celui-là ou si
vous préférez quand même
suivre Carlson même si la calife est
déjà quasi assurée pour lui
alors si il y a que des matchs nuls en
fait ce qui va se passer
il y a arme à guidon c'est ça
alors donc en fait ça dans ma Gadon qui
va se jouer à aux enchères en fait en
gros c'est pourquoi
tu prends les noirs
donc les joueurs ils vont dire bon bah
moi si je prends les Noirs je veux bien
avoir 10 minutes donc vous savez qu'on
Armageddon si on fait nul avec les noirs
et ben on gagne c'est comme gagner donc
si je joue avec les Noirs je suis prêt
pour apprendre les Noirs mais je peux
faire mieux on va être les deux joueurs
vont faire des enchères et le genre qui
aura mis le temps le plus bas ça a gagné
l'enchère et les Noirs donc par exemple
si vraiment tu verras tout prix tu mets
un temps en bas en tant que petit par
exemple se mettre je sais pas moi je
veux bien sept minutes donc tu auras 7
minutes entre 15
mais tu auras les Noirs voilà et en cas
de nul et ben tu gagnes après 7 c'est
pas beau généralement ça se joue souvent
vers les 9 10 minutes
donc c'est un peu ça bon on n'est pas
encore là et encore deux parties à jouer
une fois les blancs une fois les Noirs
chacun c'est du 15 + 3 les joueurs
ils peuvent passer plein de choses donc
ce Westling extrêmement solide il est
dur à bouger mais bon fil rouge là il
est en forme pour l'instant il n'a pas
étonnant en jeu dans les parties alors
écoutez moi je sens bien un petit Ali
resa un petit resa et d'ailleurs
intéressant aussi il y a les raisins
gagne ce match ce qui est quand même
[Musique]
possible et ben il va affronter très
probablement malus 45 parce que carcène
il l'a déjà un pion final il a déjà
gagné les deux prend en partie il lui
reste deux parties à jouer avec au moins
une nul à accrocher pour vraiment
rentrer en finale je pense que
franchement il y a pas trop trop de
suspens là-dessus ma venue va aller en
finale c'est quasi sûr mais contre qui
grande question est-ce que c'est contre
firou est-ce que c'est contre saut nous
on espère que ce soit contre firou parce
qu'on suit votre français et et voilà ça
va commencer à l'instant vous avez les
chéquiers devant vous et on attend juste
le signal pour
pour lancer la partie tout simplement
à l'IRESA à l'air débiter mais ne vous
inquiétez pas et ne l'est pas c'est il
va tout donner pour
pour gagner la partie pour se qualifier
les Noirs
souvent on l'a vu dans un magasin très
souvent c'est le langage
parce que les Blancs
ont plus de temps quand même
et peuvent plus quand même manœuvrer et
à ce niveau là et ben la couleur ça fait
quand même quelque chose donc je suis
désolé mais tu as 15 minutes avec les
Blancs contre un joueur qui a 9 minutes
et les noirs
il a moins de temps et tu mets pression
comme tu as des blancs tu peux plus
pousser de manière générale c'est
compliqué c'est pas toujours le cas
alors très souvent ça va être les noirs
des fois ça gagne etc mais c'est pas
tout le temps clair
moi j'ai vu beaucoup de fois les bons
gagnés
je suis très content parce que moi
j'aime beaucoup
les stader avec les noirs et du coup là
il va nous régaler un petit raisin qui
vous laisse un DM et on laisse la ligne
c'est une ouverture qui est de nos jours
un peu oublié au top niveau parce que
bah c'est réputé pour être un peu
difficile à jouer au très très haut
niveau alors moi je la joue encore
beaucoup et moi je la jouer encore je
pense toute ma vie
mais moi je suis pas au top niveau donc
je m'en fous et du coup les prépas
théoriques que ils ont
moi je les verrai pas donc ça me ça me
gêne pas trop
donc en tout cas c'est cool de voir
à ce niveau là donc tout à l'heure il y
a la partie il y a eu un cavalier à 6
joué par par fille
d'un dessin qui avait G4 où j'ai 5 il y
a eu des parties comme ça
maintenant à ce qui peut changer filou
il y a plein de coups possibles un peu
de cache G4
prise
pour les Noirs je sais pas
[Musique]
quelle stratégie à les réserve peut
employer dans ce match il rejoue
cavalier à 6 il retente la même
il veut tente la même et là il repart
sur des 5
donc sur un dessin
c'est quand même le coup numéro 1 tant
l'ouverture faut G5 donc je vous amène
où F6 deux coups différents il y a plein
plein de théories
mais
juste en fait
il se décide un petit peu pour savoir
laquelle il a joué tout à l'heure la
position la partie il a eu quand même
quelques petits problèmes dans
l'ouverture à l'IRISA donc là je pense
tout simplement que
Kali grisa il se dit bon tout à l'heure
c'était mal passé où est-ce que j'ai
parce que j'ai mal joué comment je peux
améliorer ça etc donc je pense qu'il
réfléchit de comment améliorer un petit
peu
la partie d'avant
mais bien sûr avec très bien leur
fichier t'inquiète pas que il va pas
jouer cet indienne pour être hors
théorie ou disait quand même c'est quand
même là on part cap d'agir du monde donc
tu trouveras pas des joueurs comme ça
qui voit qu'en théorie au bout de cinq
coups jusqu'à voilà qu'on me caresser
tout à l'heure au bout de cinq twist en
théorie oui c'est une ouverture un petit
peu spéciale quand même et généralement
tu verras jamais ça tu verras dans mes
seins
c'est plus du tout jouer à haut niveau
et donc c'est clairement la réponse que
j'aurais aussi annoncé place
très très bon contact j'aime beaucoup ce
qui faisait à l'époque
en tant que commentateur alors qu'avec
les deux c'est un goût qui avait H6 sort
tout ça c'est assez logique alors l'idée
qu'il y avait les H6 c'est de pousser
des plombs donc des fois on fait du G5
F5 des fonds
mais comme miroir
ok ok après le grand miroir ça reste
quand même malgré tout toujours un peu
épineux mais bon
alors F3 on joue solide alors ce il
reste fidèle à son style
il veut vraiment jouer tranquille et en
plus là il y avait j'ai 5 qui était
menacé et le fou en G3 aurait été perdu
donc après F3 et ben je me fais une
porte de sortie pour mon petit fou qui
peut revenir sur une case un peu mieux
que la case H4
donc là vous voyez déjà la jauge
un peu comment les autres en fait ce qui
est un petit peu ouf c'est que dans
l'Est indien l'ordinateur il aime pas du
tout les blancs à chaque fois
l'ordinateur il dit que les blancs sont
très mal
parce qu'en fait l'ordinateur il croit
pas en laisse indien alors que moi j'y
crois beaucoup mais en fait si vous
voulez rester un DM un petit conseil ne
regardez jamais la jauge parce qu'à
chaque fois lors d'un intervenir que
vous êtes foutu alors c'est pas toujours
le cas en fait l'ordinateur il aime
beaucoup tout ce qui est espace et quand
tu vois l'espace comme ça c'est bon je
fais mieux et je pense que l'ortie il
juge un petit peu trop sévèrement cette
ouverture
donc
voilà quand vous voulez être indienne
il faut vraiment avoir ça en tête et de
pas trop trop
garder l'ordinateur après il y a des
positions les positions ou clairement
les blancs sont mieux mais des positions
ou c'est pas encore si clair que ça
le Banco
dans le bain que oui mais les blancs en
plus quand même c'est quand même
différent à peu près
avec les Noirs également et mais bon tu
as un pion plus avec tes blancs donc
c'est un peu normal que l'ordinateur qui
défendent tout ils prennent un pion il
dit bah je suis mieux
l'ordi et il dit que elle est blanche
c'est un plus un 10 c'est énorme quoi
c'est énorme mais c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai
juste lui il le croit mais en pratique
c'était en plus difficile
donc voilà un banco
même si c'est compliqué je suis d'accord
tu as un pion de plus du coup
l'ordinateur et ben il dit du coup bah
je vais gagner quoi mais là il y a pas
de pion c'est la seule différence
l'ordi ne joue pas comme un humain bah
ouais c'est clair
et du coup ben à un moment donné il va
faire une précision et la PAF
le noir vont être bien selon
l'ordinateur bref
moralité l'ordi aime bien l'espace donc
il n'aime pas les Indiennes il n'aime
bien le noir donc il n'aime pas le Benco
il est bien des pions oui en fait l'ordi
tu lui donnes un pion il va dire ben
c'est quoi ça donc merci pour les gens
il va tout prendre donc dès que tu vois
un peu Gambie l'ordi il aime pas déjà et
en plus l'estandienne t'as pas beaucoup
d'espace donc l'ordinateur il n'aime pas
beaucoup
et c'est pareil quand tu joues la fille
d'or par exemple moi qui aime beaucoup
la fille d'or avec les Noirs bah tu as
peu d'espace et l'ordinateur il est
toujours que les blancs sont là dans
toutes les lignes parce que les espaces
donc tout simplement en fait regardez la
saut il a fait quoi au final saut il a
pas fait grand chose sur la partie il a
fait une partie normale etc
et il a rien fait d'extraordinaire et
pourtant il a plus 1,3
donc en fait dans ces positions il y a
plus d'espace l'ordinateur et ben il
pense que l'espace fait tout etc la
française il aime bien oui oui ça dépend
laquelle mais la française c'est pas
pareil
c'est beaucoup plus responsable que la
française dans le sens où tout ce qui
est tout le temps tous les points du roi
etc donc l'ordi il a du mal à justifier
quand même tout ça mais bon après moi je
suis pour je veux sans ordi et
franchement on s'amuse mieux quand on
joue nous-même et qu'on fait des bêtises
nous-mêmes et quand il y a l'ordinateur
qui se met au milieu ça devient trop dur
et en fait
la préparation c'est difficile quoi et
là elle résa qui a des problèmes avec ce
mecs
mais c'est vrai que c'était assez
bizarre comme coup
Dame des deux pour attaquer les 5 à 4
fois 600 attention avec du G4 qui peut
arriver donc petit rock a l'air très
bien et là maintenant il va localiser 5
probablement
ça va être le coup numéro 1 je pense
salut
pourquoi une ouverture comme la vie est
noire sur le tableau
parce qu'en fait demain il y a des
lignes qui font que c'est pas si bon en
fait si tu veux les les meilleurs
joueurs du monde les Bains ils ont des
connaissances théoriques sur les
ouvertures que n'ont pas les joueurs à
1300500 et c'est pour 100 mètres
d'ouverture comme le lundi
qui sont quasiment jamais joué au niveau
là on voit les raisins qui jouent les
indiens mais en fait à part ça on les
voit jamais et jamais jamais
la Turquie qui sont maintenant
quasi refusé alors niveau c'est trop dur
donc
moi j'adore la saint Diana ça me rend
triste ce que je vous dis mais à mon
niveau à moi je le joue encore et je
suis très content de le faire parce que
l'adversaire maintenant pas le niveau et
les connaissances et tout ça pour
réfuter en ligne
et heureusement encore sinon je pourrais
plus jouer chacun
mais du coup
voilà au niveau il y a des ouvertures
qui sont plus trop jouées à cause des
nouveaux ordinateurs des trucs qui
sortent ça devient difficile
donne de plus en plus souvent les
meilleurs coups même dans les Benco est
bizarre
pour éviter ces 5 non il veut juste
faire qu'elle aille là je pense
je pense
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi j'aime
les femmes d'accord avec toi
25 ça se joue beaucoup les semaines ah
oui mais en fait
je pense ça joue beaucoup jusqu'à
quasiment 2600 euros au dessus
de 2600 euros tu le verras pas beaucoup
c'est comme les Gambie en fait les
Gambie Budapest
toutes sortes de Gambie et bah en fait
plus tu as des lots moins que vous ce
genre de choses parce qu'on sait que
c'est pas correct et généralement moins
d'effort plus tu joues des gambille et
plus tu joues un truc pour essayer de
trappe un peu ton adversaire dans des
dans des pièges quoi mais le problème
c'est que ces pièges là les forgeurs ils
le connaissent donc ton ouverture un peu
pourri bah elle passera plus
sur la Viennoise ah mais la Réunion
c'est une très bonne ouverture
de 2300 hello bah tu changes quoi mais
tu as encore de la marge donc ça va
jouer encore alors il a beaucoup
beaucoup joué à saint-dienne Nakamura
aussi maintenant non
j'ai cru c'est que ça sent le dos bah
écoute bon courage à toi en tout cas
pour pour ta progression et tout ça
alors moi j'ai un discord mais c'est pas
ce discord de cheesecom fr je crois pas
que cheeseccumacher et un discord
par contre si tu vois sur mon discord
moi d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que je
stream et j'ai aussi une chaîne Youtube
perso donc là je suis sur chaise comme
fr mais j'ai aussi une chaîne perso donc
si vous voulez un jour venir à la voir
et venir voir un peu ce que je fais sur
mes différentes chaînes n'hésitez pas à
les voir donc là vous avez en dessous de
mon nom
le slash souffre c'est mon compte
twitch ainsi que stouf échec c'est mon
compte
cheesecom ouais pardon YouTube pardon
donc n'hésitez pas à venir voir ce que
je fais etc ça c'est sympa pour ceux qui
ne me connaissent pas voilà voilà et
sinon bien sûr je fous c'est la pub pour
cheesecom Fr donc ceux qui sont sur le
twitch ou sur Youtube n'hésitez pas
aussi à nous à nous follow ceux qui sont
sur la chaîne mais qui mais que vous
avez pas encore que vous avez pas encore
follow les chaînes et ben suivez-nous
pour pour vraiment avoir toutes les
infos et ne jamais rien rater de ce
qu'on pour vous donc ça peut être en
direct ça peut être aussi des des vidéos
des stream n'importe quoi donc n'hésitez
pas en tout cas d'ailleurs j'ai fait une
vidéo sur l'Est indiennes avec les noirs
sur ma chaîne Youtube c'est une vidéo
courte de 10 minutes et c'est destiné
aux joueurs plutôt débutant donc on
parle un peu de structure on part de
plan très simple pour joindre un truc
facile sans trop théorie donc ça vous
intéresse laisse indien et ben j'en
parle sur ma chaîne allez voir en tout
cas c'est très facile à jouer
c'est quoi le format là le premier gagne
non il y a quatre parties et le premier
enfin le fait qu'il y a plus de points à
quatre parties gagne tout simplement et
après l'égalité il y aura encore
la troisième partie il y a eu deux
parties nulle donc ça joue encore et
salut on répète merci pour mon petit
message
trop beau ces ouvertures par coeur
débutant je suis complètement d'accord
les ouvertures pour un débutant c'est
pas bon du tout je recommande la chaîne
Youtube de stools merci merci beaucoup
pour ton petit message c'est cool aussi
et
[Musique]
un anti-morin tu as juste cavalier ici
c'est toujours de la pile
c'est le plus simple
pour des pièges ah oui je suis d'accord
je suis d'accord comme le mot rat comme
le Benco je suis d'accord ça mais au
niveau ça se joue plus
on est où ça se joue plus du tout
c'est pour de je dirais de 0 à 1008 oui
c'est vraiment pas un truc long donc je
l'ai fait exprès de faire assez court
pour que ce soit un peu accessible à
tout le monde c'est une vidéo d'une
heure et demie sur une ouverture qui va
l'avoir il a fait en 10 minutes
[Musique]
on me dit de train de train les puzzles
alors les puzzles c'est hyper important
les puzzles c'est des exercices c'est
tactiques qui font affaire au maximum
quand tu quand tu débutes il y a pas
mieux il faut jouer au max analyser
c'est parti et faire de la tactique
c'est ultra important pour progresser
sur tous les sites partout on est peu
importe tu vas faire plein
pour une raison de préférer aussi OK
je m'en fous en fait j'aime bien la
Sainte Vierge
donc
c'est assez content généralement
enfin j'étais content je ça va après
la plus grande ligne c'est qu'il faut 3
la même qu'a jouer ici saut
de faux 3 je pense que c'est la ligne en
tout cas à la mode et c'est la ligne qui
est la plus forte
et donc faut trois je pense c'est la
grande ligne c'est la une qui pose
problème au nord
mais bon c'est toujours des idées dans
mes ouvertures donc ça me dérange pas
mais après c'est vrai que je préfère
comme la joue pas mais sinon ça reste
une ligne qui qui est ok je travaillais
donc même si on me la joue bah écoute ça
me dérange pas plus que ça au final vous
savez quand vous êtes prêts sur une
ouverture
c'est pas c'est pas si grave et au pire
tu apprends
sur les livres alors je suis d'accord
avec toi avec
les puzzles sur des bouquins c'est
intéressant par rapport au site Internet
de manière générale par cette force à
trouver les coupes blancs et noir alors
souvent quand tu es sur un site que soit
jescom leces ou quoi que ce soit et en
fait dès que tu joues un coup
généralement l'ordinateur il va
directement répondre avec le coup
suivant et alors que quand tu es sur
l'ordinateur
compter sur le livre et ben tu as pas le
livre qui va te donner le coup suivant
donc c'est vrai que sur le livre c'est
un peu mieux tu n'as pas d'indice et
c'est plus sympa mais après si tu as pas
de bouquin et que maintenant que
l'ordinaire qui aime tout accessible
c'est facilement c'est aussi intéressant
mais tout est possible
mais après ça dépend tu vois moi souvent
quand je suis sur moi généralement je
fais tout sur ordi maintenant mais quand
je bosse sur un bouquin c'est que je
suis dans un avion que je suis en
déplacement ou un truc comme ça mais
sinon je suis tout sur ordi parce que
c'est plus facile et c'est vrai que
c'est quand même plus
enfin maintenant les livres d'échecs
souvent sur ordi et beaucoup moins en
vrai c'est ça a changé maintenant et du
coup j'ai jean-lu moi mais c'est vrai
que je suis d'accord avec toi que les
que en vrai livre papier ça a fait quand
même des fois plus intéressant
et c'est que moi comme tu le dis depuis
des bonnes habitudes et je sais aller
jusqu'au bout d'un puzzle contrairement
à d'autres qui forcément non pas
toujours des bons réflexes et des fois
pense à la retrouver alors qu'ils ont
pas forcément trouvé
oui c'est ça quand tu es en partie et
ben en fait tu es en partie et
tu vas pas faire un coup et dire à ton
second toi dans ce qui se passe et après
je rejoins l'autre quand tu fais une
partie d'échec et ben tu anticipes tout
avant de faire ton coup c'est pareil
quand tu es quand tu as un problème
d'échec sur sur
les pièces ou cheesecom ou quoi et ben
tu dois vérifier avant de jouer un coup
et c'est pareil il faut se mettre en
condition de partie d'échec et faire la
même chose alors ceux qui prend beaucoup
de temps dans cette position
mesdames bien qu'elle a qu'elle a assez
pour moi évident pour venir attaquer
l'option de 4
c'est pas vraiment grave il y a du Fou
j'ai 5 il y a plein de cookies qui sont
intéressants pour chasser la dame noire
donc j'arrive pas trop à voir mais sur
mon explication en tout cas on va voir
ce que nous fait
ça je peux aller voir si vous voulez
rapidement ce que fait Magnus Magnus qui
on peut aller voir rapidement juste pour
voir si vous voulez
Magnus qui a qui a les blancs
Magnus 84
si qui a priori va réussir à faire nul
je pense parce que les pièces vont
s'échanger tout blanc de jouer on peut
voir peut-être un prise là on va perdre
les pions et on va réussir à échanger
les pièces
je dirais légère avantage noir pour la
part de fou et la structure un peu
bizarre mais plus beaucoup de pièces et
car les pièces blanches quand même pas
mal non plus ça risque de faire je pense
grande chance fasse nulle party voilà on
va la laisser se battre on va retourner
voir
[Musique]
on va retourner voir à l'IRESA
rapidement c'est la partie qui
m'intéresse et il a fait de la meuf de
au final il veut ramener la dame
peut-être par ici ramener aussi la tour
en F1 je pense qu'il a dû vouloir
empêcher la Mach 4 dans cette ligne
Wesley parce que au final ça devait le
déranger
donc dame F2 comment est-ce qu'on
continue avec les Noirs est-ce que Dame
de toi
peut-être pas mal
donc là
il y a des petites choses tactiques qui
peuvent arriver c'est chaud c'est
intéressant
non en fait Neo en fait c'est juste que
le score je peux le changer mais qu'une
fois donc là c'est le genre ici ça va
changer sur votre aussi donc les pages
changer parce que si le changeait là-bas
ça me changeait ici aussi donc il y a un
morceau là je l'ai pas changé ma vie ce
même de 0
c'est la seule raison pour laquelle je
n'ai pas changé je la flemme de le faire
et merci beaucoup crazy Witcher pour ton
petit message ouais ça fait longtemps
que je l'attends et ça y est c'est fait
il y a plein plein de bouquins
merci pour ta petite liste
de livres tactique pour ceux qui
ont progressé aux échecs
alors on a même deux et là il y a une
longue
réflexion de Irisa qui finalement se
décide de jouer
dans mes fuites ici pour échanger les
dames donc la pollution elle m'a pas
l'air
ordinateur il continue à ne pas du tout
aimer ça est-ce qu'on peut en imaginer
alors je sais pas du tout mais un coup
du style
échange de dames
et un fupron cavalier et un cavalier B5
essayer
3 c'est le fou qui s'ouvre le cavalier
qui va venir là j'ai plein de contre
jeux qui arrivent
mais d'un autre côté sur le long terme
c'est plus on voit très faible la chose
elle n'a pas du tout aimé ce que j'ai
proposé
mais
on sait pas dans comment continuer c'est
clair que les Blancs apparemment ont une
belle pollution
pas évident encore à
transformer en tout cas merci beaucoup
après je refais une chute parce que
c'est que je peux je suis généralement
je marche pas droit généralement je vous
recommande comme ça hop je remonte hop
et du coup bah après avoir réussi
à arriver à 2400 j'ai réussi l'exploit
et du coup derrière
on a plongé on va sombrer parce que je
suis comme ça au final je crois que je
me suis un petit peu
relâché après l'obtention du titre donc
du coup
du coup voilà mais bon je le mets un peu
sur le coup de du relâchement du titre
donc je m'en fous un peu je récupère les
points très bientôt
et voilà voilà
donc j'ai trois on va manger j'ai trois
donc
ce pion de toute façon il est faible
donc pour s'accrocher dessus bon ben
comme je vais le perdre toute façon ben
autant qu'à faire je le donne je le
pousse pour que tu puisses le manger et
avoir une structure de plan doublé ta
bonne tiens même pas il mange
faible mauvais certes mais un pion de
plus et maintenant on va sûrement manger
je veux quand même pour ne pas avoir
perdu ce pion donc avec
ces deux risque d'être peut-être le
prochain coup des
noirs ici
donc position
je pense que les autres ont encore doit
encore être précis dans ces coups mais
mais je pense qu'il y a un monde où il y
a des raisins tiennent la partie et puis
après c'est d'aller gagner avec les
Noirs donc vous avez quand même qu'avec
les Noirs un contre ce joueur
d'adversaire comme so Wesley on gagne
pas facilement une partie d'échec même
si on s'appelle la meilleure affaire aux
gens c'est vrai que généralement avec
les noirs on joue pour la qualité on
joue pour la nul parce qu'à ce niveau là
les joueurs ne commettent pas d'erreurs
des
erreurs qui peuvent leur être fatale et
pas la partie ça arrive des fois bien
sûr mais généralement les Noirs perdent
peu aux échecs et c'est pour ça que
c'est viser la nul
et ben ça va pas peur
non je pense qu'ici les noirs doivent
relativement jouer pour la
et essayer de marquer avec les Blancs
quand il n'aura ici
pas plus l'occasion de gagner quoi une
position et pour pousser un peu etc
exactement même à l'usure
je pense qu'il y croit encore et encore
et
[Musique]
en fait je pense que clairement
clairement les noirs doivent jouer pour
la nul dans toutes ces positions avec
les Noirs à ce niveau là en tout cas en
plus ça marche aller-retour donc pas le
risque avec les Blancs pareil les dents
pardon pour après
c'est avec les Noirs toujours pour pour
l'égalité pour pousser un peu avec les
dents et voir un peu ce qui se passe et
au pire des cas après de nuls il y a
encore en Armageddon donc en fait tout
simplement
à évaluer les positions qui en découlent
les finales etc
sauver une énorme bêtise un manque une
tactique juste pour vous montrer un
petit peu en fait le foot quasiment
c'est une mauvaise caisse pour les Noirs
dans la position destinienne de manière
générale et si jamais et ben tu prends
mon fou devient ouvert et mon foot
et pareil si tu prends ici mon fou qui
va s'ouvrir tout simplement et mon four
va devenir fort en un coup donc évitez
de manger ses cavaliers là avec les
Blancs là il y a une partie très connue
de camski avec le blanc contre 15 forums
ou castor il a fait cardio d'un pion
F4 et après il y a eu cavalier prend F4
puis on prend il faut prendre il a donné
un pion exprès pour ouvrir son coup de
case noire la partie elle est hyper
célèbre et avec un prof il a gagné avec
une beauté juste monstrueuse
et donc ça montre bien que ce fou c'est
un monstre une fois qu'il est ouvert
mais quand il est enfermé
pas terrible donc laissez-le enfermer ce
fou n'allez pas aider les Noirs à ouvrir
leurs propres fous c'est pas une bonne
idée il y a eu orange et même après la
prise ici franchement moi je serais
content avec les noirs pour ouvrir un
peu de mes pièces donc je pense pas
qu'il va le défendre à moins qu'il fasse
tourner fuite c'est plus pour activer la
tour que pour défendre que pour défendre
la cavalier
mais il a fait ça mais c'est pas pour
descendre pour activer la Torah
Armageddon c'est il y aura un tirage au
sort ouais sorte de de d'enchères les
joueurs vont choisir quel temps ils
veulent jouer avec les noirs et le plus
faible et ben on aura les noirs avec le
temps qu'il aura décidé d'avoir
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça donc je suis
un peu de retard lorsque vous avez écrit
les Blancs ont plus de temps mais les
noirs peuvent faire mieux
voilà donc tous les deux
comment est-ce qu'on continue à plus
qu'une minute à la conduite pour les
blancs et deux pour les Noirs attention
à so Wesley qui commence à devenir un
petit peu mal au temps
ma prise prise attention que là que je
commence à bien aimer les Noirs au fur
et à mesure la jauge et ben elle c'est
un peu réduit chez les Blancs et
maintenant de même engagement
moi j'aime bien un petit coup de tour à
8 changer d'aile pour rentrer
éventuellement par A3 et se faufiler
ça a l'air intéressant
pendant ce temps là car on a Carlson
j'ai pas du tout regardé
et
ouais il y a une pression
il y a une petite pression dans la
position regardez rapidement je vous
mets la scène avec Magnus les gens sont
partis d'ailleurs
mais je crois que voilà a battu 45 là je
vois la jauge tu vois que les joueurs
sont partis
donc je pense que carvana
a battu Magnus
mais bon ok ok c'est bien juste qu'il
perde pas la prochaine quand même par
contre
voilà la fin rapidos
si j'ai 5 G4 c'est joli quand même
j'ai 5 tu peux pas
G5 et ce matin parable je crois moi
tu prends c'est perdu tu ne peux pas
arrêter donc karena effectivement
retourner
[Musique]
Magnus c'est incroyable donc il y aura
encore une quatrième partie aussi entre
ces deux joueurs
et un magasin peut-être si Carona arrive
à gagner une nouvelle fois la partie
contre Magnus
donc 3 OK
vous avez vu à quel point comment
comment lire Elsa et ben il a réussi
quand même à trouver de l'activité dans
ma position
un peu implicite avec les joueurs qui
ont qui ont répété la position
qu'est-ce que ça va être pris
avoir un petit peu ce qui se passe mais
dans la partie on n'a pas vu ce qui
s'est passé dans tous les cas vous avez
vu que le pion qui était en 5 a disparu
comment s'est passé
il a fini mon prix en F4
que j'aime bien c'est que tout à l'heure
j'avais expliqué le fait que les Noirs
avaient du mal à manger ici parce qu'à
chaque fois ça ouvrait les cases noires
des noirs et aussi la pollution etc et
se fout de venir très très fort en G7 et
du coup il a pas hésité à donner le
Caval à F4 pour ouvrir son case noir
avec et maintenant j'ai un pion de moins
l'option qui était un E5 qui ces
sacrifié mais on commence à une tour en
D3 en 3 j'ai ça attaquer et en fait j'ai
vachement de de
d'activité pour le pion sacrifié voilà
donc du coup troisième nul dans ce match
entre Ali redafirosa et so Wesley qui
vont manger le quatrième la quatrième
partie d'ici quelques instants donc en
cas d'égalité et ben on va assister à un
mag et donc
en enchères entre ces deux joueurs par
contre s'il y a un des joueurs qui
gagnent cette partie et ben ce sera ce
sera terminé et le genre seront
qualifiés pour la finale Magnus qui
était à deux sur deux vient de perdre sa
partie donc attention ça fait deux ans
maintenant si Magnus perd encore une
fois et ben il sera pareil en Armageddon
donc ça serait un petit peu dur pour lui
de perdre deux parties d'affilée et
voire trois donc je pense qu'il va
essayer déjà le frein à main dans cette
troisième enfin pour cette quatrième
partie c'est une dans la partie qui est
faite pour départager les adversaires en
cas d'égalité
et donc en fait c'est une dernière
partie où les Noirs en cas de match nul
gagnent automatiquement la partie et en
contrepartie les blancs auront beaucoup
plus de temps à la pendule pour plus
réfléchir donc ça permet de jouer les
Noirs jouent pour la nul et la victoire
du blanc pour la victoire seulement mais
en plus de temps donc c'est un peu un
système comme ça voilà voilà
je fais un petit pause de 5 minutes et
je reviens dans un instant pour la
dernière partie de ces
de ce
de ce match entre les deux joueurs avec
éventuellement un magasin à la clé
à la clé dès que les parties sont
terminées donc je vous laisse une petite
pause et je reviens dans un instant à
tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analysez avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coûts les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
chaise.com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez streamer des échecs comme
vos créateurs préférés telstream Naka ou
les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
cheese.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors notre
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/ettings
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamer en direct votre
profites.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties offert utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
et faites grossir votre audience sans
plus attendre
[Musique]
et de retour
pour cette peut-être dernière partie
entre entre tous ces joueurs là donc on
a Magnus qui vient de se lancer et
ensuite on aura celle là qui va environ
une minute de
délai donc je mets à jour les stores
donc je suis désolé que les scores vont
pas être adaptés on va aller voir Magnus
Magnus ici
[Musique]
hop la partie la partie 2 de saut contre
les raisins qui a toujours environ une
minute de délai donc dès que ça commence
je pense qu'on ira voir à l'IRESA et so
plutôt que 45a mais comme cela commence
en premier on va commencer par celle-là
et
l'exorcent installés vous les voyez
ta bille à des blancs et doit absolument
gagner pour pouvoir arriver au départage
il a rejet ces quatre tiens marrant
et Magnus qui fait le 5 qui change cette
fois-ci
B4 ça c'est membre c'est mon répertoire
aussi je joue avec les noirs
et là je joue sous le set qui a un des
coups il y a plein de coups possibles
ici
il y a plein de coups possible on peut
jouer full et 5 il y a aussi un coup
marrant c'est fou et fuite
de 5 il y a plein d'idées assez
intéressantes et donc fousser 5 avec les
jouets ici par Magnus
comment va-t-il répondre normalement E3
je pense c'est un coup assez logique où
j'ai droit
ici non je surveille la partie de la
livraison
voir quand elle commence pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir y aller donc E3 a été joué
par Fabi qui prend sa petite tasse de
thé
Cavalaire
jouer
alors ici on a un weekend de manger le
Cavalaire
de joueurs donc c'est marrant
des 5 si tu manges du père le plan B4
donc tu as mangé en D4
et du coup les blancs sont contents ils
ont gagné la paire de fou
donc cavalier F3 on peut avoir E4 on va
voir aussi le D6 ou d'abset possibles
pour défendre ce petit pion en S5 il y a
quand même des cartes qui va arriver
très vite donc je pense peut-être que 4
ici doit être un des coups principaux
des noirs
[Musique]
le problème de de 4 des Noirs c'est que
sur un long terme peut-être que les
Blancs un jour arriveront
à mettre un fond en B2 et plus tard à
jouer des trois
et avoir la rupture pour ouvrir la paire
de fou sur le roi d'un noir comme moi
j'ai les fous moi je veux des ruptures
et je veux un jeu
au centre
donc ça peut être aussi l'inconvénient
de 4 mais je pense que j'aurais joué à 4
de toute façon c'est parti
j'aurais joué 4 pour sur avec les noirs
donc petit jouet
il y en a maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
joue directement les trois
aussi possible mais j'ai l'impression
qu'avec ce petit pion en 4 il faut
roquer quand même assez vite je ferai
des trois mois je pense
aussi F3 dans le même dans le même style
mais j'ai un peu peur d'ouvrir mon roi
vous voyez
plutôt ça
après deux trois pions
désolé ici c'est pas forcément sur donc
on peut jouer pour la paire de fou et
l'initiative pendant que mes pions sont
pas forcément très bon
ou alors avec F3 mais F3 c'est
un peu plus risqué j'ai l'impression
qu'il a fait à 4 ok
un couple j'aurai jamais fait de ma vie
alors en fait clairement Carolin il veut
dominer
le damas cette fois trois arrière et
vraiment prendre tout le contrôle de
l'espace ici alors bien sûr il rentre
quand même de ce côté là ne vous
inquiétez pas mais il veut vraiment
gagner cet aile à tout prix donc écoutez
Magnus va peut-être D6 va être possible
sans faire des pièces ou tout revu de 5
trucs comme ça et essayer de vite en
profiter pour attaquer
le roi blanc de l'autre côté B6
j'ouvre la colonne A intéressante
donc prise prise X3 on peut imaginer un
truc comme ça
de ce type là tout va vite et un jour je
commence à bien aller les Noirs parce
que je trouve que les noirs peuvent
gagner un peu l'initiative après
tous ces échanges là
en fait on suivait à l'IRESA et on va
suivre maintenant on va changer
et comme tu dois t'expliquer et ben je
ne peux pas
[Musique]
enfin je peux changer le score à chaque
fois mais c'est le score qui
change pas en fait
donc ce soir j'avais dit pour cette
partie là mais dès que je change de
partie il faut être le rechange le score
à chaque fois donc je vais un peu la
flemme donc en fait ça c'est le score de
Ali raisin et sur Wesley le vrai score
de Magnus contre
car voilà c'est 2-1 pour malheureuse
donc Magnus il faut une nul pour gagner
et se qualifier pour la finale du campus
sport
tandis que
so Wesley et alimentation à trois
parties nulles chacun
donc
[Musique]
tout reste à faire s'il y a une victoire
dans des deux dans la partie et bien ce
jour là se qualifiera en finale contre
le joueur en face donc
il y a des grands champs que ça va mieux
pas encore terminé mais le genre se
qualifiera en finale en tout cas là-bas
et si la partie fait encore match nul et
ben il y aura
il y aura une dernière partie qui se
jouera en Armageddon entre ces deux
joueurs
[Musique]
donc il joue pour le gain avec les
Blancs c'est tout à fait
normal
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
directement
prendre le centre est-ce que je fais
cavalier d'eux pour commencer votre
cavalier en 3 vous savez que cette
manœuvre donc qui va ranger 3 elle est
hyper connue dans tout ce qui est
espagnol italienne c'est le plan on va
dire de base de ces positions
A4 qui qui souvent se joue beaucoup
histoire de manger là et d'ouvrir la
colonne de la tour il y a plein de
coupes possible ici pour les blancs
moi perso je pense que je ferai des deux
parce que des quatre trop tôt j'aime pas
trop moi je ferai ça ça et après
j'essaierai de faire des quatre je pense
je serai plus dans cette optique là là
il y a eu à 4 OK
un 4 donc l'emmenage de manger là est
ton contour donc il va falloir défendre
la tour après il y a plusieurs écoles
qui a tombé vite qui se joue des fois
pour défendre le pion des cinq et pour
s'enlever du vis-à-vis de la tour c'est
intéressant c'est le goût jouer on
aurait aussi pu à la place je vais
foulard au foulard mais ici ce Wesley a
décidé de faire plutôt embell 8 solide
donc prise très c'est un coup c'est
normal parce que ça ouvre la tour et
donc ça empêchera caballer à 5 qui ici
pourrait un jour être une menace coup de
cavalier alors une fois que je prends
prends ma ta plus cavalière
ce qui se passe par exemple prise et
cavalier 2 c'est la partie
prise qui est de alors tout à fait
correct d'être plus tard ma cavalier F1
gettera et puis ça se passe bien
quand une fois sur deux les blancs avec
les Blancs il faut essayer de montrer un
peu un truc donc c'est normal tout à
fait normal de de jouer avec les banques
si tu fais nul sans jouer avec les
Blancs
et je peux vous garantir que si Ali resa
mené au score et ben il aurait pris la
nuit
pense qu'à défier donc c'est juste par
rapport au match c'est tout à fait tout
à fait normal de la jouer ici
après ça
[Musique]
quand même
soit il aime bien il aime bien être en
paix généralement quand même
après quand il a quand il faut gagner il
est là mais
c'est pas le joueur le plus on va dire
le plus Fighter dans le
dans
le groupe des meilleurs joueurs du monde
oui il a battu Magnus non mais c'est
clair c'est un très très bon joueur
alors ça ça c'est clair c'est un
excellent joueur so Wesley mais
en termes de combativité c'est pas le
grand numéro 1 c'est pas Magnus c'est
pas c'est pas Ali resa qui joue à gagner
en toute partie il y a un petit peu plus
solide il joue quand même il prend
beaucoup moins de risques que beaucoup
d'autres joueurs quand même
bah c'est vrai il est beaucoup moins
entreprenant que
que votre genre en fait je l'ai même vu
dans les enfin c'est une interviews
souvent il est il a il est pas en
confiance
quand il entreprend un peu mal il dit
voilà je compte lui il est quand même
très fort et tu sens que tu sens que il
est
[Musique]
je sais pas moi je pense que il est
extrêmement fort c'est un joueur qui qui
pourrait être encore plus fort que ce
qu'il est maintenant mais que du coup
mais que du coup
il se sous-estime un peu par rapport aux
autres c'est mon avis personnel sur So
wesle je pense qu'en partie rapide en
partie Blitz en même on l'a vu aussi en
cas random il est extrêmement fort je
pense que en général il est extrêmement
fort aux déchets mais je pense que c'est
sous-estime beaucoup par rapport à
d'autres joueurs
et beaucoup de fois il prend des nuls ou
il prend des décisions un petit peu
pleutre parce que bah il
dit que c'est il dit que c'est bien mais
c'est un excellent joueur c'est un vrai
top 10 c'est un joueur voilà mais par
rapport à d'autres joueurs c'est vrai
que c'est un joueur qui qui va beaucoup
moins chercher l'embrouille voilà et que
des fois la nul ça me va bien tranquille
ça va c'est cool
dans mes sacs par rapport à d'autres
joueurs on voit même qu'un voisin on
voit les joueurs qui vraiment veulent
gagner quoi ça voit aussi que
Kawana il a eu il a eu plus de 2008
pendant toute sa vie il a un peu baissé
mais on voit quand même la différence de
résultat de palmarès entre certains
joueurs et ce Wesley qui annexe l'argent
ça veut dire mais il est tout le temps
deux trois quoi vous voyez il gagne
rarement des tournois bon là il a gagné
160 donc c'est pas un bon exemple mais
c'est un joueur qui est pas beaucoup de
temps par rapport à un carbone à par
exemple par rapport à un même un fil
rouge donc c'est un genre qui est
beaucoup plus solide mais qui va moins
gagner parce que ben il va pas perdre
mais il va moins gagner
donc c'était différent là je je
compare pas youtube avec SOS lait ça n'a
rien à voir absolument rien à voir
mais juste ce que je disais juste c'est
que je trouve que so Wesley il est il
est beaucoup moins voilà entrepreneur je
pense c'est vraiment le mot que je t'ai
refais beaucoup moins entreprenant que
d'autres joueurs
de manière générale après quand il est
là quand il est dos mur qu'il faut
gagner une partie ben il va te faire
pour la gagner quoi et c'est clair mais
une partie sans vraiment dangereux il va
pas s'embêter et il va jour plus simple
je pense enfin c'est ce que je vois
depuis des années et des années avec SOS
après ça empêche pas que c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde et encore une
fois ça je vous dis que cette attitude
là il a contre les gens du top top
niveau là demain a amené le faire un
Open et vu qu'on des grands maîtres à
2500 hello bah là il va essayer d'être
bien plus entreprenant parce que les
gens à 2600 hello il va il veut tous se
battre quoi
donc là c'est pas ça un truc très
intéressant regardez
sauf Vichy un moment pour jouer ici
cavalier prend avec 4 cavaler prend 4
qui a regardé un pion mais après fou à 7
et ben il y a une découverte sur la tour
et le cavalier ici
et alors
j'imagine qu'il est quand même
ça peut aussi être un coup de fatigue
mais il a quand même anticipé j'imagine
fois 7 qui vient attaquer les deux
pièces donc là la jauge qui quand même
donne au noir un peu la belle-fille du
doute on voit que 0,27 c'est pas en plus
un avantage écrasant
mais quand même c'est une qualité
c'est une qualité
cette fois F5
mais je mange
donc il y a un pion
pris pour la qualité pour le noir j'ai
une structure c'est une majorité qui va
pouvoir peut-être
se développer via F5 plus tard le fou
qui maintenant est bloqué derrière le
pion des 5 donc je pense que les Noirs
veulent avoir du contre jeu là dessus
mais j'ai l'impression quand même que
c'est assez intéressant pour pour aller
raisin et que peut-être qu'il peut aller
jusqu'au bout grâce à ce fou assez
intéressant est-ce que peut-être qu'il a
juste oublié
ça qui se dit mais peut-être qu'il
pensait
et qu'il avait pensé qu'elle allait
prendre un F2 ou quoi que ce soit
mais c'est vrai que là
dans le chat j'ai aladino qui propose
deux c'est une grosse faute et les
problèmes de parce que j'ai en F2
et là ciao là je mangeais quand même une
pièce pour pour
[Musique]
pour Juan pion
pour deux pions et c'est pas suffisant
c'est pas suffisant c'est trop de
matériel d'avance et tes pièces sont pas
assez développées pour vraiment avoir du
jeu
donc ça ça n'irait pas et après faut à 7
et à ceux qui fait un peu la tronche
donc ça ça peut aussi être
[Musique]
ça peut aussi être je sais pas du tout
si il a halluciné ou pas
à la fois tout le dire et à la fois rien
dire parce qu'à ce niveau là en fait
les joueurs si tu veux calculent très
très bien tous pour être à 2007-2008
calcule tous extrêmement bien et après
tu as des styles de joueurs qui sont
plus attaquants que d'autres mais en
termes de calcul des joueurs ils se
valent tous à part peut-être Magnus mvl
et quelques jours comme ça qui calcule
peut-être plus vite et un peu mieux que
d'autres mais sinon genre plutôt
tactique moi j'ai d'autres tactiques que
que
[Musique]
bien attaqué par exemple
on aime plein de parties il y a des
parties extrêmement bonne alors je sais
pas si vous l'avez si vous la connaissez
et une partie je crois que c'est une des
plus belles parties que j'ai vu toute ma
vie c'est la partie de
mvl avec les Noirs il y a le gros morose
et vite
c'était à
Bienne en 2009
regarde elle est là sur Internet
bien 2009
mon rosévitch mvl c'est monstrueux
monstrueux
et tu reprends et tu reprends le 4 il a
pas cru il a pas cru
a donné la qualité la préfère donner une
pièce plutôt qu'une qualité c'est assez
étrange comme le choix quand même
fontaine mvl spray France avec
convention cavaliers très très connue
aussi mais la partie que je vous dis la
partie de contre morose et Beach
c'est c'est oufissime
officiellement complètement faux
c'est un truc de malade
salut bonheur
je comprends plus rien les gars je
comprends plus rien
alors que se passe-t-il là si je fais X5
tours
du Fou sur la tour et la récupère la
pièce
ok c'est pour ça qu'il est un jeu
cavalier des deux
pour défendre ici et si jamais on
maintenant qu'elle va laisser 8 et ben
je bouge mon fou et Madame des fois un
tour ah c'est jolie franchement les gars
il calcule calcule bien il rate rien et
donc il y a eu ici cavaliers d'eux qui
d'ailleurs un coup un coup brillant de
l'avoir de cheesecum et du coup ben
quand même deux pièces pour la tour
c'est après la prise ici et ben j'aurais
deux pièces pour la tour et un bel
avantage aussi pour pour aller raisin
qui va peut-être réussir à transformer
cette quatrième partie en victoire et
éliminer ce résumé de la poule des
gagnants
saluteoffre bien agressif aussi
[Musique]
oui c'est bien ça c'est bien ça sur OK
c'est une sorte de nage d'or bizarre
donc
il y a eu un cavalier en E6 avec les
plans très tôt et la partie c'était
en 2009 ça date et c'est une partie
monstrueuse de la part de MVM
mais à cette partie mvl moi c'est une
partie qui m'a toujours hyper
impressionnée après il y a aussi la
partie est un peu trop Robert fontaine
où il avait où il a fait une promotion
cavalier à la fin pour terminer très
jolie aussi mais ça c'est plus une
combine finale qui a été jolie quoi
alors la partie contre contre morose et
vite c'est une partie
juste les deux joueurs
ils ont fait une partie tous les deux
parce qu'il faut être deux enfin une
belle partie c'est une partie qui était
d'extraterrestre tout était en l'air
et mon rosé c'est un joueur qui lui a
vraiment l'antithèse du pleutre avec
tout pour gagner mais tout tout tout
tout et une partie morosevic contre un
VL ou les deux veulent gagner il sera
tout dans la gueule franchement c'est
beau franchement c'est beau
cette partie là la dernière
partie votre Ding
ouais je sais plus laquelle
mais je crois que contre ding ding il a
fait une grosse erreur je crois
c'est pas je trouve que c'est un peu
différent
par rapport à par rapport à la partie de
la nouvelle ou là vraiment depuis le
début c'était un combat mais là c'est
vraiment un vrai combat quoi alors que
là quand tu joues bien etc d'un coup tu
gaffes et que tu prends une belle
tactique oui c'est une belle partie mais
là la partie de la nouvelle c'était
jusqu'au bout à la fin il y avait à la
fin il y avait il y avait une tour de
plus pour un VM la tour elle jouait pas
enfin c'était vraiment c'était juste
trop bref regardez cette partie et vous
m'en
direz des nouvelles cette partie c'est
mon rose et vide cmvr en 2009 à Vienne
on dirait des nouvelles
c'est une des plus belles parties que
j'ai vu toute ma vie
sans blanc a fait une vidéo sur la
partie Moro mvl
ouais bah je savais pas tu vois
[Musique]
et peut-être que je ferai une vidéo
d'ailleurs là-dessus
parce qu'elle mérite quand même elle
mérite cette partie
comme c'est 8 donc là on est en weekend
de faire fout aux trois tempo
mais
il le fait pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'il le fait pas est-ce
qu'il y a un problème tactique après
tout reprend d'un point S5 et là quand
je bouge mon cavalier ici il y a F4 mon
fois plus de case je peux aller là-bas
mais bon c'est moche
ou alors
G3 et fourchette
je pense à un problème
qui
marche un peu dessus
est-ce que tu as des jeux qui avait
juste le temps
et maintenant
je pourrais faire ça sans qu'il y ait de
fourchette
mais si je fais ça peut-être dans le B7
si je bouge le fou tu prends ma tour et
tu me dévie de la défense du plan de 5
là ça commence à faire
[Musique]
du tout
comment est-ce qu'on joue c'est pas
facile
de tout
c'est quoi le nom de ta vidéo pour
demain
[Musique]
tu peux l'avoir sur ma chaîne tu vas sur
tout fait chèque tu cherches j'ai plein
de vidéos mais on est une c'est pas un
short c'est une vraie vidéo qui dure
environ 10 minutes c'est sur l'Est
indienne donc le fond il est noir je
crois mémoire
c'est Oliver
la particular merci merci
qui qui prend son temps il veut vraiment
bien jouer prendre aucun risque car elle
prend un sac pour trois car elle est
prend à 5 pour X3
pourquoi donner une pièce alors G4 c'est
aussi un coup d'extraterrestre qui va
empêcher F5 je comprends bien
mais
c'est quand l'affaiblissant et si
maintenant je le coup d'âme des 7
avec tout à l'heure prise prise et là
attention qui est quand même un tout qui
est ouvert c'est un peu chaud
c'est un peu chaud ici ce qui se passe
mais du coup alors il fallait je crois
sur l'ordinateur je triché un peu
ok pourquoi
pourquoi parce que c'est le meilleur
coup
si je fais ça
j'ai pas ça je suis bête ah bien sûr
l'idée et du coup il y avait qu'un Vadé
prendre des 5
c'est un coup bizarre quand même penser
à toi
ok bon j'ai quatre alerte quand même
plus humain apparemment c'est pas que
tout mais il faut qu'ici que que ce soit
hyper
hyper hyper précis parce que ce n'est
pas précis bah c'est quand même à deux
pièces pour la tour
c'est gros avantage quand même pourra
lire et donc là ça va une partie très
compliqué pour les deux joueurs mais
c'est plutôt les Noirs je pense ici qui
doivent être précis salut Mika
ouais c'est clair ça fait ça fait plus
classe de voir un petit i à place du F
en vrai ça fait plus classe on va
enlever les bras
les bras du F
ubé 6 faut B6 sur
il me semble du du
il a joué ce que j'avais pris du poids
je pensais à la dame à deux taper
là-dessus mais dans la douche je pensais
assez six ouf je prends encore waouh
malgré ça faut qu'il arrête quoi ça va
être deux coups deux coups
brillants dans la partie là tu es obligé
de gagner après de cobrian alors
pourquoi c'est coût brillant parce que
surpris on prend ben j'ai fou prendre
les sacs très jolie
sur dame prend des 5 et ben j'ai
fourchette royale même familial si vous
voulez il y a toute la famille sur la
fourchette
du coup il faut prendre un H6 ça enlève
la défense de la cadavre 6
mais après bon ça c'est alors niveau
c'est
standard là je vois que le chat est
impressionné moi je le suis aussi en
vous inquiétez pas mais c'est très
standard alors niveau de faire ce genre
de choses vous inquiétez pas c'est
normal à la place de G4 mais avec quand
même tout reprendre il faut et pour
prendre il me semble peut-être que j'ai
des bêtises
c'est quoi le problème
actuellement
je prends tu prends ok intéressant ton
truc
mais c'est pas sûr ça suffit quand même
prise je mange
c'est intéressant
il me dit F5 et là tu
es pas bien
voilà
donc ouais mais très bonne idée en tout
cas t'en fous bien ici c'est très malin
j'aime bien
du tout vraiment fallait juste c'est ça
que c'est le seul coup qui donne la
position égale pour le noir c'est le
seul coup et après cavalier
ici écoutez
les les Blancs ont une position
quasiment gagnante
il y a deux pièces pour seulement
tourpions avec le roi qui va être ouvert
donc on peut imaginer qu'elle va les
prendre foutrant et après ramener la
dame pareil ici ça a l'air quand même
pas mal faire attention à ce qu'avec
plus tard mais ça a l'air quand même pas
mal pour pour les blancs
que jamais vu et ouais et avec des
explications ce serait intéressant parce
que tu as la tour qui était en H8 qui
repart en H7 qui revient c'est des trucs
de ouf
et en plus l'ordinateur il est pas
d'accord mais bon c'est normal c'est les
humains qui jouent une partie une partie
trop trop ouf mais bon
allez ça il envoie
a été joué on garde ici on joue avec des
4 et là c'est perdu vous pouvez les
Noirs chez cavalier F5 qui va arriver
j'ai une dame qui va venir sur les
gasoil donc à ce niveau là on Boisse les
sceaux il va quand même se battre pour
pas perdre quand même trouver des
ressources mais
normalement
[Musique]
allez résa ça arrive pas la perdre il a
quand même 4 minutes à la pendule contre
deux
cavaler F5 déjà pour empêcher roi et 7
et ensuite tu fais dame tu passes
ça a l'air complètement gagnant
pour pour aller résa qui va se qualifier
pour la finale peut-être
je vais voir Magnus où il en est
rapidement Marius elle est noire
écoutez Magnus
Magnus Magnus
c'est chaud
très très chaud malgré
on va aller voir dès que c'est fini là
ce serait marrant que sur Magnus qui
fasse les départages alors que les deux
zéro et que ça veut dire que c'était
impossible qu'il fasse un départage je
l'ai bien pointé quand même bon c'est
pas clair encore il a pas perdu mais la
position allait elle est elle est où il
va jouer trois c'est sûr
il faut jouer au 3 pour couper la couper
la voix de la dame par laisser faire la
marche
de partout c'est sûr qu'il va jouer au 3
Demba c'était monstre
j'aime pas du tout alors là damage
système pour un ça va système pot je me
lasse d'un point F6 je me lasse dans ma
chute je me lasse plein plein de choses
la finale ce sera demain mais en fait il
y a plusieurs finales après je vous en
reparle si tu restes là Lucas après je
vous en reparle de quand est la finale
parce qu'en fait ça c'est un comment
dire un format un peu bizarre il y a
plusieurs finales
c'est un truc un peu bizarre
est-ce que les Français
on a deux joueurs qui sont en top qui
était en top 10 mondial
mais oui aux échecs on a quand même
de très bons joueurs après bien sûr les
meilleurs joueurs ça reste quand même
les pays un peu comme la Russie et
dernièrement c'est les pays un peu comme
l'Inde aussi la Chine
ont extrêmement fort aussi mais la
France c'est quand même un pays qui
progresse
du monde jeune en moins de 8 ans ce qui
me trompe pas
et donc pas mal de petites de petites
stars qui qui montent
donc dommage 7 échec d'un point LCS on a
plein de choses ça a l'air très très dur
pour les pour les noirs
c'est des Miss monstrueux ah oui on a le
meilleur ami de France là il y a ici sur
sur la chaîne en direct
et pendant ce temps car scène on va
aller voir aussi
on va aller voir aussi
et -10 aussi effectivement les deux à
moins de 8 et moins de 10 quand même en
même temps c'est bien ça et en Belgique
vous avez aussi un excellent joueur
de 1600 Hello
et ceux qui a plus de temps mais qui
tente quelque chose mais bon
position est trop dur
moins de 8 ans c'est environ 2000
en tout cas le numéro 1 français il a
maintenant il a 2100 kg je crois à peu
près mais bon ça va à l'heure quand même
intéressant
et il y a un jour en Argentine il a quel
âge en Argentine il a il a 9 ans je
crois
et il a 2300 kg
ça calme ça calme pas mal quand même
2300 et 9 ans
pas mal
[Musique]
et moi je l'ai d'ailleurs joué ce joueur
j'avais joué en stream il y a quelques
peut-être un an ou quelques mois l'avait
joué et j'avais dit mais je peux pas
perdre contre un enfant de 8 ans quoi
pas possible et j'avais réussi à faire
perdre mais j'avais fait une nul à
gagner deux ou trois parties
mais bon le gamin il était hyper fort
quoi il avait il avait sur cheescom 2800
du tout alors là attention il va falloir
faire peut-être un coup d'échec quelque
part si tu prends là échec et chèque et
chèque pour voir il a fait prise échec
là pour prendre avec le fou ou la dame
pour défendre le petit fou ici et
récupérer la tranquillement c'est pas
encore fini encore échec là
et sur voilà j'ai échec prise etc je
pense terminer il a mis le roi en B8
et maintenant je peux manger
tranquillement parce que sur
l'avantage d'avoir je l'avais pas
c'est pas qu'on fait la vidéo mais ça va
ça va ça va partir très très vite je
pense que dès que le tournoi existe
termine ce sera terminé et
allez tu gagnes la partie abandon de de
saut dans cette position et les joueurs
qui sont vite parti ils ont rage quitte
donc on a on va vite rattraper la partie
de Magnus quel est noir enfin cette
position ma venue ce qui
a une pièce de moi mais il a quand même
plein de pions qui va Adam par ici
une pièce de plus monsieur le choix il y
a plus beaucoup de pièces quand même
Magnus tient la partie
pour la finale par contre Marius perd
cette partie et ben
il y aura Armageddon ce qui est assez
incroyable d'avoir un magasin quand tu
m'aimes de zéro quand même
de base quand tu m'aimes de 0 contre
tu vas perdre deux parties d'affilée
c'est pas un truc qui arrive souvent et
donc il faut savoir que la finale donc
les gens d'une part de tour
on retourne fou c'est nul théorique
donc là on a venu c'était pas contre
échanger une tour donc cette position
qui est je pense censée être nul
qui me fait attention il y a quand même
un fou de plus mais même si par exemple
j'arrivais à faire ça et ça ce serait
une théorique en fait tu reprends tout
reprend échec tour fou de retour c'est
nul normalement c'est nul après en
pratique il faut encore la défendre je
pense pas que ma nuit se la perdre mais
il y a toujours un petit peu il y a
toujours un cas où on peut où on peut la
perdre
donc voilà mais bon cette position je
pense que normalement elle est plutôt
sans risque pour Magnus
mais bon avec peu de temps la pendule on
sait jamais on va un peu ce qui va se
passer
en tous les cas
si Magnus perd cette partie il y aura un
magasin s'il arrive à ne pas la perdre
et ben il se qualifie directement pour
la finale contre Ali résa firuga qui
vient d'éliminer ce Wesley
donc
qui va affronter le vainqueur de ce mini
match
on aurait bien boire demain un petit
haliresa Magnus
on aimerait bien et c'est demain la
finale mais attends attends 2 secondes
une seconde de Toto
je vais rappeler un peu les règles et le
format parce qu'en fait il y a plusieurs
finales ce format est un peu bizarre il
y a plusieurs formats format différent
le score ou le score excusez moi le
score je l'avais mis pour l'autre match
donc là le score c'est de 1 pour Magnus
le change merci beaucoup pour le score
ouais je l'avais en fait j'avais mis
pour l'autre match et quand je switch je
garde le score il faut que je change
manuellement je l'avais pas fait
donc tout aussi ça a été joué et
maintenant bah écoutez
essayez de changer les pièces
veut échanger les pièces cette position
qui
devrait être nulle mais
c'est un peu ça ouais c'est un peu ça
[Musique]
donc Magnus qui
nous solide et il a raison il est
complètement raison
Caravana de cette partie jusqu'à la
jusqu'à la mort il a raison parce que
c'est lui qui pousse il a une pièce de
plus Marius peut se tromper et en plus
enfin voilà et en mustwin il est mené
dans le match donc il est obligé de
de Joséphine d'ailleurs ce qui va se
passer à un moment donné vous savez que
la règle des 50 coups sans prise ni
mouvement pion je sais pas combien de
coups ils en sont mais j'imagine que ça
va pas tarder à arriver donc
karwana ce qu'il va faire c'est qu'à un
moment donné quand il va arriver vers
les 45e coup et ben il va proposer un
échange de Tours
parce que dès qu'il y aura un échange de
pièces on va recommencer après les
prises ni mouvement pion
dans la prise il faut que je vois je
peux regarder moi-même aussi
je vais regarder
je crois en C3
exactement
j'ai mal lu donc 60 + 50 ça fait 110
donc là on est au 100 on a encore 9
coups à tenir
sinon c'est nul donc je pense que
carwana aurait intérêt à échanger une
tour ça fera nul quand même oui mais au
moins il pourra réessayer 50 coups
pour un réessayer à 50 clous
donc ça c'est la stratégie
très les joueurs ils ont terminé ça se
voit sur leur écran
mais chez nous c'est pas encore terminé
il y a encore trois coups chez nous pour
échanger une pièce ou bouger un pion et
malgré ma musculation en GSF il le
bougera pas parce que Ben se faire nul
donc il a pas intérêt à relancer 50
coups l'adversaire
et plus qu'un coup
tu reprends G7 forcer ça va faire mieux
ok ça fait nul
c'est marrant que manus fasse tourner 6
parce que sur tout prend les 6 et ben il
va relancer l'adversaire pour 50 cours
encore donc c'est pas un très bon coup
en pratique pour les 6 tout est bon sauf
ça et d'ailleurs ici tu reprends le 7
était le meilleur coup
pour essayer de tenir essayer de jouer
après tout reprend G7 j'ai ou on
reprend là et maintenant c'est final
elle est nul théorique mais tu peux
encore la gagner sur un malentendu les
gens sont mal au temps c'est jamais
facile en pratique même si c'est
manuscade qui sait faire en pratique il
y a toujours un cas où tu peux la perdre
et comme c'était en plus le 50e coup
sans prise ni moins de pions tu reprends
le 7 ça relancé tout à zéro il met 50
coups de nouveau à faire avec cette
finale qui est quand même nul théorique
à ce niveau là je pense pas que le
problème pour la défendre mais en
pratique tu as une chance de pouvoir
gagner il fera saisir il faut y aller il
faut la tenter et ça n'a pas été le cas
dans cette partie donc petit résumé
rapide regardez bien le bracket il est
ici
avec toutes les Timis à jour donc on a
Magnus Carlson qui a battu karwana 2 et
demi et qui rejoint du coup furuza qui a
aussi battu 2 et demi so Wesley pour la
finale donc là vous voyez il y a marqué
winners final et maintenant le vainqueur
de la finale de demain sera calé pour la
grande finale qui à l'autre bout de
l'écran à droite et en fait ce vainqueur
de la finale
affrontera le vainqueur de du bracket
des loosers qui est tout en dessous
d'accord et par exemple là on voit que
maintenant saut il est dans le loser
finale et car voilà aussi et maintenant
et ben les joueurs qui sont dans le
carré d'en bas ont déjà perdu un match
quand tu perds un deuxième match tu es
out là on voit que tabac abeille est
alianov sont tous les deux out ils ont
perdu deux matchs
et maintenant vous voyez qu'il y a sur
le zavik car on a Abdou qui vont se
jouer en quart de finale et après
revenir en demi-finale et je vous la
finale et le vainqueur de la finale
affrontera Carlsen
et si bac à sen dans un match et ben
Catherine aura lieu aussi perdue un
match donc il y aura encore à votre
match voilà donc du coup c'est encore
très très chaud et tout est encore
possible on avait vu un cas où il y
avait un argus qui avait perdu son
premier match je rencontrais artemief
et qui t'est arrivé en finale des
loosers contre Nakamura il avait quand
même perdu la finale mais on peut
toujours se refaire c'est c'est jamais
fini donc c'est vraiment deux matchs
perdus tu es éliminé un match tu joues
encore donc du coup voilà et est-ce que
les raisins a une vraie chance
bien sûr
là j'ai vu le match à lireza hier il a
mis 3 ans à Abdou aujourd'hui 2 et demi
à Sceaux en parlant zéro party en étant
jamais en danger il est 45 il a quand
même perdu une partie contre Kawana et
là dans la partie est également à moitié
foutu aussi donc 45 il gagne tout c'est
le meilleur mais en parlant de forme bah
écoutez je suis pas complètement sûr que
que
[Musique]
oui et Laurent aussi d'ailleurs j'ai eu
Laurent tout à l'heure par message et
Laurent nous rejoindra demain pour
débriefer un peu son tournoi c'est parti
rapidement pendant qu'on aura un coup de
pause donc
je l'ai eu par message et demain on va
le suivre on sera de suivre quand même
et
en même temps de le faire venir sur la
chaîne pour débriefer un petit peu tout
ça voilà voilà en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne on va s'arrêter là pour
aujourd'hui demain on reprend à 17h le
match car cette fille sera peut-être un
peu plus tard généralement on a vous le
savez on a le match déperdant en premier
et ensuite la finale donc aujourd'hui on
a on a vu le match des des gagnants on
fait environ 19h30 20h donc un truc
comme ça et du coup on ne se connaît pas
la suite en tout cas je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée à tous
je vous dis merci d'avoir suivi le
string c'était vraiment très agréable
avant de compagnie je vous dis à demain
pour encore plus d'aventure et à très
bientôt bonne soirée à tous ciao ciao